Estelle Youssoufa. Bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Serview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Estelleoufa, je suis euh la députée de
la première circonscription de Mayotte
qui est le nord de l'île qui part de du
village d'A qui va jusqu'au chef-lieu
Mamutzu et qui inclut la petite terre.
Donc la première circonscription de
Mayotte euh il y a le chef-lieu donc
Mamutzou, il y a le port de Longonie, le
notre seul port euh commercial et en eau
profonde. Euh l'aéroport, l'hôpital,
euh la base de la de l'armée, euh la
centrale de production électrique.
Voilà,
on vous fait revenir parce que on est
très très attaché à Mayotte et c'est
surtout un point géopolitique,
géostratégique très important pour nous
pour des questions de flux migratoire,
pour des questions de flux de bateau, de
marchandises, d'accession à certaines
ressources autour de l'île.
Première question, est-ce que la
reconstruction s'est bien passé ? Avant
de commencer la la première question sur
la reconstruction,
le chef d'étatmajor des armées qui dit
qu'il va en guerre dans 3 4 ans qu'il
faut se préparer à notre force d'âme, du
moins renforcer notre force d'âme, ça a
fait quelques bruits dans la
représentation nationale. Est-ce que
c'est arrivé jusqu'à Mayotte ?
Ben, je pense que si ça a fait du bruit
dans la représentation nationale, bon
comme on était né dans le budget puis
que bon à l'Assemblée en ce moment c'est
le budget mais en commission de défense
qu'a annoncé le chef d'étatmajor on l'a
déjà entendu hein, c'est pas non plus
une information. Euh je suis un peu moi
personnellement assez surprise de l'écho
que ça parce que pour nous les
territoires ultramarins, que ce soit la
Nouvelle-Calédonie ou Mayotte, la guerre
elle a déjà commencé. Mayotte, elle est
déjà comme la Nouvelle-Calédonie,
l'objet d'attaque hybride de la part de
la Russie. Euh très forte, très directe.
De quel type ?
Du du type déstabilisation
avec les fausses informations très
importantes.
La rumeur.
Euh Ah non, non. C'est beaucoup plus fin
et vraiment spécifique. C'est-à-dire moi
sur ma page Facebook, il y a des des
centaines de bottes des faux profils qui
sont créés pour appeler au départ de la
France qui utilise qui appelle à l'aide
Poutine, qui demande l'intervention de
la Russie, qui utilise tous les conflits
sociaux euh pour avec de l'intelligence
artificielle modifier les discours que
l'on peut tenir. Il y a comment dire une
instrumentalisation sur Russia Today,
sur les Twitter sur X forte. Alors,
c'est pas que la Russie, c'est aussi
l'Azerbaïdjan avec le groupe de Bakou
qui instrumentalise la question de
Mayotte et tout ça en appui des comor
qui se sont rapprochés beaucoup de
Moscou qui jouent le jeu de Moscou, le
chaud, le froid pour stresser le qu
d'ors qui vient tout de suite ramper dès
que Azali va faire la bise à Poutine ou
que son chef d'étatmajor fait un tour à
Moscou ou que l'ambassadeur de
russe qui est dans la région va à qui
est à Madagascar va à Moscou et à Moroni
pardon comor vient d'annoncer par
exemple qu'ils allaient ouvrir un centre
culturel, multiplier les efforts et
cetera. Donc on voit vraiment une
offensive très forte de la Russie sur
Mayotte.
C'est une stratégie de guerre froide.
C'est une stratégie qui en fait
est tout à fait liée à l'engagement de
la France en Ukraine. C'est-à-dire que
le discours de Lavrov et de du président
Poutine compare Mayotte à la Crimée en
disant
et en disant voilà nous on a fait un
référendum et les Criméens ont voté pour
devenir russe. Bah pourquoi est-ce que
vous vous refusez que Mayotte soit
française ? Donc elle est pas française
parce que eux ne sont pas ukrainiens.
Enfin bon, ils ont refait toute une
sauce pour appuyer la revendication
comorienne. C'est allé très loin parce
que les Russes vont maintenant à dire
par tous les moyens appuyer la
revendication comorienne. Donc si vous
voulez la menace militaire, elle est pas
du tout voilée, elle est explicite. Et
euh nous ce qu'on observe à Mayotte,
c'est quand même depuis euh 4 ans un
influx massif de demandeurs d'asile
africain. Vous savez que le problème
Vous savez que le problème de migration
à Mayotte, c'est principalement et
historiquement des comoriens, nos
voisins, qui instrumentalise les flux
migratoires pour asseoir leur
revendication territoriale. Les comor ne
reconnaissent pas Mayotte française et
donc envoient leur population
littéralement coloniser Mayotte. C'est
pas moi qui le dit, c'est les autorités
commoriennes qui le revendiquent,
l'assument, vont le dire à l'ONU et sont
à fond derrière ce discours. Seulement
depuis 3 4 ans, en fait, elles ont non
seulement elles continuent à envoyer
leur population, mais elles organisent
la traite avec les migrants qui arrivent
d'Afrique et qui eux ne sont pas des des
migrants des clandestins comme les
Comoriens Mayot, ce sont des deux
mendeurs d'asile. Donc, ils ont tout à
fait d'autres droits. Et donc on voit
depuis plusieurs années arriver par un
flux croissant des africains qui
arrivent de la zone des grands lacs
de Somalie, du Soudan, du Yémen qui
arrive en passant par les Comors.
Les trafiquants et les autorités
comoriennes
les accueillent les font passer pour
ensuite les envoyer à Mayotte. Les
demandeurs d'asile à Mayotte, comme dans
le reste du territoire national ont
droit à la protection jusqu'à ce qu'il
leur dossier soit examiné. Ça veut dire
qu'on doit leur doit un logement et de
la nourriture. Faut imaginer qu'à
Mayotte où il y a strictement rien et où
on a même pas accès à nos droits
fondamentaux, cette catégorie de
migrants protégés qui est totalement
étrangère à la culture locale,
on est
noir de peau à Mayotte, musulman mais
c'est un territoire insulaire. On est
d'origine swili mais aussi malgache. Il
y a des influences historiquement arabes
aussi mais c'est une culture très
spécifique notre culture maorise.
Les personnes qui arrivent des grands
lacs du Burundi, du Congo ou par exemple
de Somalie arrive de zone de conflit
porteur de d'une idéologie pour certains
une idéologie politique
d'une violence traumatique ou qu'ils ont
fuit, qu'ils amènent avec eux et qui
terrifient la population mais qui
terrifient la population et qui sont en
plus porté par des associations
qui utilise Mayotte comme un territoire
d'expérimentation pour pousser le droit
des réfugiés et qui donc sont dans une
revendication qui est extrêmement
organisée mais aussi violente. Par
exemple, quand il y a eu le cyclone, les
réfugiés ont été hébergés dans des
établissements scolaires et quand il a
fallu qu'on reprenne les établissements
pour que les cours reprennent, ils ont
détruit les établissements scolaires en
exigeant un logement dans une île à 90 %
détruite ou endommagée.
Ce que j'essaie d'expliquer, c'est pas
que Mayotte n'est pas accueillante. Ce
que j'essaie de dire, c'est que vous
n'observez pas subitement un afflux de
migrants qui sont des demandeurs d'asile
avec des droits particulier
sans la coopération et l'instigation
d'un pays étranger, c'est-à-dire l'échor
et pour moi de manière totalement
apprise par les Russes qui ont
expérimenté ça avec la Biélorussie. Si
vous vous en souvenez, l'Europe de l'Est
avait été déstabilisée par un afflux
massif qui avait été organisé par les
alliés russes pour des demandeurs
d'asile et ça avait déstabilisé
subitement Schengen et de se dire
comment est-ce qu'on fait face à un
afflux. C'est exactement ce qu'organise
les comor sous pour moi l'instigation
des Russes. Et ça marche. Turquie la
Turquie fait marche. Exactement. Mais ça
marche. Ça marche pourquoi ? parce que
les demandeurs d'asile sont des
personnes protégées. C'est le droit
international.
Ça marche parce que ça crée une
compétition victimaire obsène, atroce de
personnes qui sont dans une vraie
détresse face à des gens qui ne peuvent
pas les aider.
Ça ça organise et ça importe une
violence à laquelle la société maoraise
ne sait pas faire face et ça déstabilise
complètement les services publics parce
qu'il n'y a pas du tout les
infrastructures à Mayotte pour la
population déjà locale indigène, encore
moins avec les migrants comoriens. Mais
alors les demandeurs d'asile qui
arrivent
ultra violent, porteur de traumatisme
extrêmement grave,
on s'est retrouvé avec une histoire
complètement folle d'un Palestinien qui
s'est mis à multiplier les agressions
pour que les autorités le renvoient à
Gaza. un demandeur d'asile qui était
fou, qui est devenu fou mais qui est
quand même allé agresser violemment
plusieurs personnes et et et être
dangereux et porter des coups. On a des
par exemple les violences le mouvement
social qui a été déclenché au printemps
2024 a été déclenché par
les migrants, les demandeurs d'asile qui
étaient massés au stade de Cavani et qui
refusaient de laisser ce lieu public qui
était un établissement dans lesquels les
enfants allaient faire du sport. il
refusait de l'évacuer, il l'avait
transformé en camp au milieu des
habitations et la population s'est
soulevée après des mois où nous les élus
en avant appelé au gouvernement en
disant "Vous pouvez pas laisser
s'installer ça, c'est anormal, c'est
dangereux, ce n'est pas possible, c'est
un nid à maladie." Ils étaient
présidente de l'Assemblée passe par là,
elle répète doctement les mots de la
préfecture, ils sont 300 400. Ils
étaient 1500 1500 à faire évacuer. Et là
on vient d'évacuer un camp à Tsunzu, ils
se sont déplacés à 300 m, 1500 aussi.
Femme, enfant, mais mais c'est délirant.
Et c'est des personnes qui en plus
arrivent sur une île qui est
complètement détruite où il n'y a pas eu
de reconstruction. Positez la question.
et et où en fait ils exigent des droits
qu'on ne peut pas auxquels on ne peut
pas répondre. Et le la demande d'asile,
vous on vous rejette pour la demande
d'asile. En fait, normalement vous devez
partir. Sauf qu'ils viennent de zones où
on ne peut pas les expulser puisque ces
zones sont en guerre. Et là-dessus,
comme pour le reste, il y a pas de
solidarité nationale pour dire on va les
prendre.
Voyez, l'hexagone regarde et en tout cas
les autorités regardent et disent "Bon
ben, vous allez gérer." Bah on peut pas
gérer parce que là maintenant, on se
retrouve avec des combats à Mayotte
entre les demandeurs d'asile africain et
les Comoriens qui ont décidé que il y
avait rien de mieux que de se battre et
puis nous Maoré, on est au milieu
spectateurs, victimes, complètement oage
de cette folie de cette folie. Notre île
est devenue un camp à ciel ouvert, ce
qu'on avait évoqué ensemble il y a
plusieurs années avec maintenant une
hybridation de la menace qui qui est
exponentielle. C'est-à-dire que
et quand je parle d'une menace, c'est
qualifié par l'Union européenne et par
l'OTAN comme une menace hybride.
L'instrumentalisation des flux
migratoires. J'utilise pasisation.
migratoires est définie par l'Union
européenne comme l'OTAN, comme une
menace hybride. C'est quelque chose où
en fait l'objet de cette menace c'est de
saturer les services publics et de
retourner l'opinion
pour créer du désordre et du chaos. Le
cas d'école, c'est Mayotte.
C'est une ingérence étrangère qui est
pilotée par les comorts avec un script
qui est envoyé par Moscou avec l'aide de
l'Azerbaïdjan et vous êtes en train de
faire sauter s'effondrer ce territoire
français de l'océan Indien. C'est un
département. On n'est pas on a voté pour
rester français et on se retrouve en
moins d'une décennie à avoir des
arrivées quotidiennes
pour les demandeurs d'asile environ 150
à 200 par mois. C'est énorme sans
compter les arrivées continuelles de
Comorien qui viennent et qui maintenant
se sont lancé depuis le cyclone dans une
opération qui est monstrueuse pour
Mayotte de déforestation. le cyclone a a
déforesté
et en fait les Comoriens et et les
clandestins ont décidé qu'il brûl qu'il
restait pour faire avancer les
bidonvillees. Donc en fait, on a encore
plus de bidonville qu'avant. Vous avez
entendu là tous les tout tous les les
sinistres ministériels là qui sont venus
qui se sont succédés pour nous dire on
va vous aider patati patata on va lutter
contre l'immigration clandestine. On a
demandé à corps et à cri de dire vous
devez arrêter et dire que pendant cette
catastrophe il y a plus de
régularisation on arrête. On ne peut pas
accueillir on peut pas. On peut pas. Le
gouvernement a refusé et ben on a
continué à accueillir. On a encore plus
de bidonville qu'avant. L'île a eu une
série d'incendies qu'on a jamais
volontaire volontaire pour chasser les
gens et pour augmenter la taille des
bidonvillees. Voilà. Donc si vous voulez
le le la question migratoire à Mayotte,
c'est une question éminemment politique,
pas de politique intérieure pure, c'est
une question internationale et ça a
beaucoup de sens de comprendre ce qu'il
se passe pour effectivement prendre la
mesure de la gravité de la situation. Et
je pense que quand on voit la réaction
de nos compatriotes par rapport à ce qui
se passe à Mayotte, ils ont tout à fait
l'intuition que ce qui se joue là-bas
est grave. Les autorités, l'État
minimise et préfère qu'on en parle pas
trop. Mais quand moi je parle avec euh
monsieur madame Michu dans la rue qui me
reconnaissent avec mes couleurs ou qui
me disent "Ah mais vous venez d'où ? Je
viens de Mayotte. Mais madame mais ce
qui se passe chez vous c'est pas
possible. Mais comment c'est possible ?
C'est inadmissible. Laissez tomber des
Français comme ça. C'est c'est
incroyable. Et en fait, vous savez, on
se dit nous, on est tout petit, on fait
375 km², on est euh 400 500000, on est
très peu. Euh on est français depuis
1841, mais la plupart de nos
compatriotes sauraient même pas nous
mettre sur une carte. Et pourtant, ils
s'identifient à ce qu'on vit. Ils nous
reconnaissent notre caractère d'être
français et ils se disent si on
abandonne Mayotte, le territoire le plus
pauvre, le plus vulnérable, on nous
abandonnera aussi. Et c'est vrai parce
que si la décision de l'État c'est sur
un territoire ravagé par un cyclone,
vous ne financez pas pendant 1 an la
reconstruction. Là, moi à Mayot, je n'ai
pas eu de reconstruction. On n'a pas eu
de On n' pas eu un centime de reconstru
rien. On a eu de l'aide et des secours.
Ça n'a rien à voir avec la
reconstruction à Mayotte. La préfecture
est toujours sous une bâche, les gens
sont toujours sous des bâches. 90 % de
la population n'était pas assurée. Sur
les 10 % qui ont été assurés, seulement
20 % d'entre eux ont été remboursés.
Aujourd'hui, à 1 an après le cyclone,
seulement 20 % des 10 % des maor qui ont
été assurés ont été remboursés.
C'est-à-dire que les assurances ne
veulent même pas rembourser et quand
elles assurent, elles vous donnent le
chèque et elles vous disent "On met fin
au contrat et on quitte Mayotte."
Ça c'est la réalité. L'autre plan du
gouvernement, c'était de dire "Bah oui,
bah comme il y a 90 % de la population
qui est pas assurée, on va vous donner
un prêt à ta zéro."
Je
faut le dire avec calme. 52 dossiers
acceptés par les banques. 52 dossiers de
près à taux zéro de 50000 € pour
financer vos travaux. Quel que soit le
montant de vos dégâts,
une dette
50 dossiers acceptés,
c'est le degré de de
d'abandon par le pourrissement et
l'inertie est à peine imaginable.
À peine imaginable.
Les gens sont complètement désespérés.
Moi, pour moi, c'est un échec terrible.
C'est des efforts. C'est c'est de se
battre avec ici à Paris
un concours l'épine de la connerie.
Souvent, je dis à mes interlocuteurs, on
dirait que Shido est passé chez vous,
hein. Vous êtes fatigué de ne rien
faire. Je parle à des gens dans des
ministères qui me disent, c'est
compliqué. Qu'est-ce qui Qu'est-ce qui
est compliqué ? Tu reconstruis.
En plus, vous avez eu le toupé au
gouvernement de nous imposer que la
reconstruction se fera avec du
préfabriqué,
des containers qu'on a combattu comme
des malades mentaux. J'ai jamais vu un
lobbying pareil et franchement faut
l'étudier chez Syerview. J'ai jamais vu
un lobby pareil de gens qui vous disent
"On va construire en 22 de on va
recycler des containers où on va vous
vendre du du prémé, du préfabriqué.
Moi, je me suis égoillée à l'assemblée à
dire "On connaît votre vos containers là
parce qu'on en a déjà. Ils sont partis
comme des petites boîtes en carton là
pendant le cyclone.
Ces chosesl là, elles surconsomment de
la clime et on ne produit pas assez
d'air condition d'électricité à Mayotte
pour tout mettre comme ça.
Vos professeurs, vos fonctionnaires, vos
policiers n'accepteront jamais de vivre
dans des containers.
Donc vous allez faire fuir les gens dont
on a besoin pour construire cette île.
Et on vous a demander du dur. On vous a
pas demandé d'aller vite.
Personne à Mayotte ne vous a dit d'aller
vite.
Non mais ce sera moins cher. Moralité.
Non seulement ils ont toujours pas
reconstruit même avec leur préfabriqué,
mais en plus quand ils vont daigner nous
amener leur préfabriqué, nous on va
devoir se farcir
une île en container.
Ça vous laisse en voie nous ça nous
notre est défigurée par un cyclone. La
réponse de l'État c'est on va affiler
des container climatisés.
Ah ouais, on vous a dit pendant des
années que vous preniez une
responsabilité énorme avec les vies
humaines que vous laissez s'entasser
dans les bidonvillees. Ils ont tous été
rasés par le cyclone. Là, il y en a plus
qu'avant.
Là, je suis dans les négociations sur le
budget. Je n'arrive pas à obtenir le
parlement s'est engagé sur 4 milliards
pour reconstruire Mayotte.
OK, je n'arrive pas à obtenir le
décaissement.
C'est que des belles paroles.
C'est de la programmation mais ce n'est
pas budgé.
C'est joli la sémantique hein. La
sémantique c'est du réel à Mayotin. Ça
fait 1 an que les gens n'ont pas vu un
sous. Nos entreprises sont à genoux,
elles ont entamé les travaux et en fait
l'État paye pas, ne décaisse pas. Les
communes ne n'ont pas reçu d'argent. Il
y a rien. Il y a rien. Moi le cyclone
pour mémoire quand même le cyclone chido
est passé le 14 décembre 2000 24.
Il y avait le gouvernement Barnier était
tombé.
Donc en fait, il y avait pas de
gouvernement. Si le président de la
République n'était pas venu, il y aurait
pas eu une autorité,
personne pour venir à Magotte. Rota le
ministre Rota est venu 1h30,
il est reparti puis on a plus jamais eu
de ses nouvelles.
Président de la République est venu,
est resté 2 jours, est venu avec un
avion complet avec des haut
fonctionnaires, des militaires pour
aider et pour soutenir.
Ce que l'État n'a pas dit et qui aurait
peut-être mieux expliqué la situation,
c'est que la destruction de Chido, c'est
90 % du bâtiment à Mayotte dont la
gendarmerie, la base militaire, la
préfecture, la Croix-Rouge, la police
nationale, les pompiers, tout a été
détruit. L'aéroport aussi. Donc en fait
les gens ont pensé qu'il y aurait des
secours alors que l'État même était à
terre.
Et dans cette période, et je suis pas
macroniste, je n'ai pas appelé pour son
élection, on est certainement pas
d'accord sur un milliard de choses, mais
s'il n'était pas venu, vu qu'à Paris
tout le monde était en train de courir
après son petit portefeuille
ministériel, je peux vous dire que j'en
ai pas eu un seul au téléphone
sur la plus grosse catastrophe
climatique.
Ça vient de quoi ce ce cette passivité ?
Ça vient de quoi ? C'est on a pas
l'argent. Ils veulent pas reconstruire.
Ils veulent abandonner Mayotte. Il
disent que c'est un trou exposé au flux
migratoire, que ils se font déstabilisés
avec les Russes, que ça nous sert plus à
rien, ils veulent laisser tomber les
mains oreilles. Ça ça vient de quoi le
fait que un département français qui se
prend l'équivalent d'une tête nucléaire
sur le le sur la tête qui est exposé à
des flux migratoires dramatiques,
imaginez-vous une épidémie de quoi que
ce soit, de choléra ou de quoi que ce
soit qui débarque à Mayotte. dans ces
conditions, en a déjà une. Et de la
lèpre et de la lèpre
et de la lèpre et e ça vient de quoi ?
C'est ils en ont rien à faire, ils
veulent les abandonner. Il ils ont
renoncé à leurs outre mères, à nos outre
mères.
En fait, je pense que on peut parler de
Mayotte, on y reviendra, mais en fait,
je pense que ce qui se joue et qui est
complètement invisible ici, c'est une
nouvelle étape de la déconisation.
et et en fait ici dans l'hexagone, on le
lit pas du tout, on comprend pas ce qui
se passe dans les outresem. Il y a quand
même une bascule historique qui est très
très importante. Les outres mers, c'est
trois océans. Sur l'Atlantique, vous
avez les Antilles et puis la Guyane. Les
Antilles sont
vieillissantes. Elles ont fourni dans
les années 60, 70 et 80 euh beaucoup de
Français qui sont venus à la poste, à la
police, dans les hôpitaux qui ont vidé.
pour en faire des négropolitains mais
qui ont vidé
de leur sèv et donc c'est département
vieillissant
la mais c'est dans l'imaginaire
collectif en métropole les outremères
c'est les enters
bah oui
et c'est des territoires qui ont des
esprits brillants, qui ont beaucoup de
ha fonctionnaires et qui donc sont très
importants, sont des voies importantes
sur la la lecture et la politique
ultramarine.
Et dans l'Atlantique, il y a aussi la
Guyane qui est un territoire qui est
beaucoup plus jeune, qui s'est senti
méprisé et maltraité par les Guyan par
les par les les Antillet et qui pousse
et qui pousse dém démographiquement et
qui est sur des ressources colossales
en minerais, en en pétrole, mais aussi
avec l'Amazonnie, avec d'autres
ressources
de biodiversité mais aussi inexploré
et qui sont sur une zone de croissance,
un bassin de croissance énorme
sur laquelle Paris a décidé de geler le
foncier,
interdire trop de progression
territoriale pour les la population et a
interdit toute exploitation des
ressources qu'ell soi pétrolières
ouifères.
Donc on laisse les orpailleurs
s'enrichir.
Les Guyanais, on les laisse Paris les
laisse dans une violence et une misère
qui est indigne. Mais vous voyez que sur
le bassin atlantique, je n'oublie pas de
mentionner Saint-Pierre et Miclon qui
est quand même tout proche de du Canada
qui se retrouve alors que Paris a même
oublié son existence mentionnée par
Trump.
Voquier qui dit bah quand j'ai des
délinquents, je les envoie à
Saint-Pierre Miclon. Bonjour la
considération.
Voyez, ça c'est la dynamique
atlantique, c'est-à-dire une bascule au
sein même de la France de l'Atlantique.
C'est ça. Ultramarine Atlantique, c'est
ça la France du Pacifique, c'est la
Nouvelle-Calédonie,
la décolonisation la plus sanglante, la
plus chaotique, la plus problématique
actuellement.
la Polynésie avec le passif
nucléaire qui fait qu'il bénéficient
d'une rente, mais ils ont un statut de
pays d'outre mer qui donc eux sur sont
sur une logique euh d'autonomie plus
avec un discours d'indépendance
poussé par d'autres
bah qui est endogène et puis qui a
alimenté avec un coulé chinois, un coulé
Azerbaïdjan gens pas mal l'Australie
enfin ils ont ils ont plusieurs
courtisans qui qui les aident mais je
veux dire il ils ont aussi des
souverainistes qui sont pas très aidés
par Paris.
Vous avez les marquises qui elles sont
pas du tout sur une logique
indépendantiste
qui sont donc pour ce territoire polyn
de
du Pacifique sur une logique où vous
êtes soit sur de l'indépendance, soit de
l'autonomie. Euh pour la Guyane aussi un
gros discours autonomiste.
Euh parfois pour les Antilles un
discours indépendantiste ou autonomiste.
Et vous avez l'océan Indien avec deux
territoires. réunion qui est la vitrine
ultramarine pour Paris qui a mis
énormément d'argent où il n'y a aucun
passif colonial esclavagiste
qui met mal à l'aise Paris comme c'est
le cas avec les Antilles parce que c'est
ça aussi le fond, il est racial. C'est
pas la même chose. La vitrine qui est
présentée à la Réunion, c'est la
diversité, le vivre ensemble. Bon, pas
quand il y a des maor qui vont là-bas,
mais c'est un autre sujet. Et puis vous
avez Mayotte.
Alors là la Réunion, il y a un discours
un petit peu autonomiste
indépendantiste, mais en réalité pas du
tout.
Je veux dire, c'est le territoire
d'outre mer qui reçoit le plus de
transfert de l'État, qui est à un niveau
de vie qui n'est même pas comparable
avec les autres territoires ultramarins
et qui est pas du tout questionné dans
son importance stratégique par
vous avez Mayotte
française malgré Paris. Ça est français
depuis 1841. On nous a interrogé un
milliard de fois pour demander est-ce
que vous êtes sûr sûr sûr de le rester ?
Oui oui oui. Et puis en fait bah dans ce
monde qui change euh Mayotte en fait
elle redevient très stratégique parce
que Mayotte notre voisinage c'est quoi ?
C'est le canal du Mozambique. Donc c'est
à 500 km de Mayotte le Mozambique avec
les plus grosses réserves gazière qui
doivent sortir l'Europe de sa dépendance
du gaz russe.
C'est pour ça que l'Union européenne
investit massivement au Mozambique de
manière complètement invisible et
inexpliquée pour ceux qui ont pas
compris le fond du sujet.
En fait, c'est que le Mozambique c'est
des normes en réserve gazière qui sont
en partie exploité doivent être exploité
par Total mais aussi en Éni la compagnie
italienne Gasprom et Russes aussi des
Coréens aussi des Japonais. Tout ça
c'est ces réserves. Les réserves du de
gaz du Mozambique sont plus importantes
que celles du Qatar, plus importante que
celle que l'Algérie. Et en fait
technologiquement on ne pouvait pas les
exploiter parce qu'elles étaient en eau
très profonde et maintenant on peut.
Donc voilà, c'est logisement de demain
connu, exploitable. C'est ça. Daesh en a
entendu parler. Donc il mène des
attaques extrêmement violentes et donc
l'exploitation ne pourra se faire que
offshore, c'est-à-dire elle ne pourra
pas se faire du sol, elle pourra se
faire qu'en mer. Le port français à 500
km, c'est Mayotte.
Donc Paris et les Réunionnés peuvent se
retourner par terre. La géographie, elle
est ce qu'elle est. La Réunion fait
partie de l'archipel des Mascareng de
l'autre côté de Madagascar.
Ce n'est pas dans le canal du Mozambique
et donc c'est Mayotte qui est en
première ligne pour participer à
l'exploitation gazière mais aussi pour
être attaqué par Daesh si un jour ça
leur passait l'esprit puisque vous
comprenez que la porosité d'une
frontière telle que Mayotte qui n'est
pas protégé peut évidemment et
logiquement nous vulnérabiliser avec un
voisin qui est particulièrement
malveillant.
Je rappelle pour celles et ceux qui
seraient dans l'angélisme que les
Comoriens avaient quelques
ressortissants lors des premières
attaques d'Al-Qaïda à Dares Salam qu'on
a retrouvé des Comoriens qui
combattaient en Syrie, qui combattaient
en Irak. Donc c'est pas un pays de
bisous. Il y a une radicalité qui est
violente et notre crainte à nous à
Mayotte, c'est d'en être un jour
victime.
Il y a aussi des Français qui ont été
pris la main dans le sac chez Daesh,
chez Akmi.
Bah oui. Et puis là-dessus, l'État agit.
Pourquoi est-ce que il n'agit pas pour
Mayotte pour nous protéger de nos
voisins ? Pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait
toujours preuve d'un angélisme délirant
à à avoir des gros bisous pour le
président Azali qui est quand même un
général pchiste he qui maintenant est en
train de mettre en selle fils et sa
femme pour faire une dynastie
d'eau corruption
qui revendique à l'ONU
Mayotte qui est allé chercher euh parce
que quand même il faut il faut faut voir
la personnalité et le charisme du
bonhomme hein. Il est incompréhensible
en français. Il ne ressemble à rien. Il
a quand même eu l'intelligence
diplomatique d'amener en disant les
demandeur d'asile africain, d'amener
l'Azerbaïdjan, d'amener la Chine et
d'amener la Russie dans la question de
Mayotte.
Il est en train avec beaucoup de talent
de mettre complètement en échec la
France dans l'océan Indien, dans le
canal du Mozambique.
Fait quoi ? qui regarde et il encourage.
Moi, je vais vous dire, je vais vous
dire ce que fait le qu d'ors mon dernier
ma dernière sortie en commission des
affaires étrangères, c'est l'agence
française de développement qui vient
d'annoncer qu'elle soutenait un projet
de 247 millions pour construire des
ports comoriens.
Notre port, le port français de Longonie
qui devrait servir Total et les autres
compagnies pétrolières a été en grande
partie détruit par Shido, par le
cyclone. Il est en train de s'effondrer.
Ça nous pose un sujet. 90 % de ce qu'on
mange, de ce qui doit servir à notre
reconstruction dépend de ce seul port.
L'État n'est toujours pas foutu de me
sortir un centime pour reconstruire
notre port. Mais l'Agence française de
développement vient de soutenir et
d'aider à monter ce dossier pour les
ports comoriens.
Et vous avez eu monsieur Riou, le
président de l'Agence française de
développement qui vient d'expliquer hier
au Sénat, oui, vous comprenez, c'est
très important. Si les Comoriens vont
bien, tout le monde va mieux. Ah ben je
sais pas. Moi moi j'ai dû j'ai dû
manquer un épisode
dans dans mon catéchisme. Charité bien
ordonnée commence par soi-même en fait.
Quand vous avez un département français
dans laquelle l'agence française de
développement intervient l'héritage du
colonialisme, c'est-à-dire que l'Agence
française de développement qui travaille
en Afrique, en Asie travaille aussi en
outreem. souvent ce que les gens
ignorent. Et bien euh l'Agence française
de développement, elle trouve que c'est
beaucoup plus pertinent d'aller donner,
même si ce n'est qu'une partie, elle ne
donne que 5 millions sur ce projet de
247, mais c'est elle qui l'a monté parce
que c'est la France qui est derrière
pousser un dossier comorien auprès de la
Banque africaine de développement, la
Banque mondiale,
le FMI alors que c'est un pays qui est
ultra corrompu. Vous pensez bien que
c'est pas Zazali là qui est allé
défendre ça hein. C'est pas c'est pas
son génie à lui. C'est le qued d'ors qui
est allé servir de caution au niveau de
l'Union européenne pour aller dire non
non, on s'assoit sur les rapports
parlementaires, sur les rapports de
l'Union européenne qui disent ce pays
est corrompu. On ne on ne reçoit jamais
le moindre retour sur nos
investissements. On n jamais la suite de
de la dépense. On ne sait pas où va cet
argent. Et ben Paris mais non mais non.
Et le la discussion que je peux avoir
avec le chef de l'État, c'est de dire
Estelle, tant que Azali reprend les les
Comoriens, c'est mieux. Mais non, en
fait, moi ce que j'essaie de lui
expliquer, c'est que cette logique du
chiffre, c'est un échec le plus complet.
On n' autant de comien à Mayotte. Ils
ont utilisé et ils abusent le droit du
sol pour devenir français et pour
revendiquer Mayotte parce que c'est pas
parce qu'ils ont la nationalité
française qui perd de leur revendication
territoriale. Au contraire, ce que
veulent les Comoriens à terme, c'est un
référendum,
un cheval de 3.
C'est un cheval. Évidemment, évidemment,
c'est ça l'idée, c'est le renversement
démographique
et comme le quai nos génies de
diplomates dont on voit le succès dans
leur politique africaine et l'humilité
d'apprendre de leurs échecs, de se
remettre en question, jamais.
Donc en fait, ils disent "Non, non, non,
il faut continuer à se prosterner devant
le président Azali, devant les autorités
comoriennes et ils n'ont toujours pas
compris qu'en fait on est en train de
perdre le match." Le sujet c'est pas
vous pouvez vous dire "Bon bah oui,
enfin bon, un tout petit caillou 355 km²
après tout, c'est pas si grave." Bon,
alors je vais juste rappeler le discours
officiel de la France sur ses outre mè.
La France siège à l'ONU parce qu'elle
est sur les cinq continents
grâce à ses outre mères. Elle est sur
les océans grâce à ses outre mères. Le
problème de la France, c'est qu'elle a
pas compris qu'il y a des ultra marins.
En fait, on n'est pas juste des
tremplins stratégiques. On est aussi des
Français qui avons des droits auxquels
on n'accède pas. On n'accède pas droit à
l'eau, on n'accède pas à nos droits
humains, on n'accède pas à l'égalité
républicaine. Et donc il y a quand même
un gros problème et qu'aujourd'hui le
virage historique dont je parlais, c'est
que la stratégie de Paris, quand vous
écoutez la revue nationale stratégique
ou le chef d'étatmajor dont vous
parliez, il parle de protéger l'hexagone
et il ne protège pas les outresemères.
Et moi quand je discute avec
mon collègue de Nouvelle-Calédonie,
je lui dis "Tu sais le sujet c'est que
les Russes posent à Paris un dilemme
stratégique.
Les Russes ce qu'ils font c'est
d'appuyer sur les territoires d'outre
mer, là où c'est douloureux
pour emmerder Paris,
pour provoquer des crises internes et
pour souligner l'indigence et la
fausseté du discours.
Ils ont pas besoin de beaucoup parce que
la déstabilisation et l'ingérence ne
crée pas un problème, elle l'amplifie.
Le problème, il est existant.
Il faut pas laisser croire que les
Russes créent le problème à Mayotte ou
dans les autres territoires ultramarins.
Militaris,
c'est juste qu'il l'amplifie, il le font
savoir et puis ils le nourrissent. Il y
a pas d'eau, c'est un fait. C'est pas
les Russes qui ont coupé l'eau à
Mayotte, c'est la France qui a pas
investi pour qu'on ait de l'eau dans des
territoires français. C'est ça la
réalité. Donc faut arrêter d'aller se
dire "C'est Moscou qui est derrière."
Non non, pas se cacher derrière son
petit doigt.
Le problème c'est que dans le chaos
mondial dans lequel on est, Paris est en
train Paris et on est qu'au début, Paris
est en train de se dire il va falloir
protéger l'hexagone et en fait on est en
train de lâcher les outresem et ça c'est
un virage qui est pas ce n'est pas qu'un
problème pour les ultramarins.
C'està-dire qu'alors que la France
questionne sa puissance,
quand elle renonce à ses outreemères et
ses ultramarins,
elle peut oublier sa puissance.
Faut arrêter de se raconter des
histoires. Moi, je n'ai pas la capacité,
même en étant élu, de faire changer le
cours de de la politique. Ma seule
capacité, c'est de porter la voix de mes
concitoyens et de bien faire comprendre.
Et je l'ai toujours dit à mes
interlocuteurs officiels, je ne peux pas
vous empêcher de larguer Mayotte et de
nous abandonner, mais par contre, on va
pas crever en silence. Faut être bien
clair. Si vous décidez que vous
abandonnez un territoire national
contre la volonté de ses habitants
parce qu'on est pauvre noir et à 10000
km de Paris
musulmans souvent.
Il va falloir que vous revoyez toute la
posture de la France au niveau de
l'Union européenne,
auprès des Corses, auprès des
Calédoniens, auprès des Bretons, à
l'ONU. que vous expliquiez pourquoi
est-ce que vous êtes contre le
fédéralisme
belge ou contre celui qui se pratique
en Espagne que vous expliquez que vous
revoyez toute votre politique
internationale et que vous justifiez
votre siège à l'ONU parce que vous êtes
plus qu'un tout petit territoire
européen dans un continent vieillissant
avec 3300 milliards de dettes.
Oui, mais ça ce n'est que des choix.
Ce n'est que des choix. Non, ce n'est
que des choix.
Vous vous choisissez vos priorités. Si
vous avez décidé que vous mettiez des
centaines de millions d'euros pour aller
développer le solaire en Inde mais que
vous avez pas d'eau dans vos territoires
national,
on récolte ce qu'on s'aime.
Il a des phénomènes de corruption autour
de la de Mayotte de l'argent qui aurait
dû arriver mais qui est pas arrivé qui a
été intercepté. Rien.
La corruption ça c'est un sujet
intéressant. Parce que la corruption à
Mayotte est utilisée comme un argument
pour ne pas faire la reconstruction. Je
m'explique.
Il y a un maire qui a présenté une
facture de 12 millions d'euros pour des
travaux de nettoyage
d'une entreprise qui a été créée la
semaine d'avant et des travaux son
cabinet a travaillé à œuvré présenté à
la préfecture. Le préfet déclenche un
article 40.
Le procureur fait toujours sa sieste et
le bonhomme est candidat.
Et vous voyez sur France info ou France
Interre apparaître un petit papier. La
corruption pourrait retarder
la reconstruction à Mayotte.
Moi, j'ai jamais entendu dans l'hexagone
pour toutes les affaires de corruption,
on va priver les citoyens d'une zone où
il y a de la corruption. une corruption.
Article 40 pour ceux qui savent pas
c'est quoi ?
Non, l'article 40 c'est que un un
fonctionnaire doit absolument dénoncer
ou un élu doit dénoncer tout acte
délictueux ou de corruption ou criminel
à la justice ne peut pas le taire. Donc
le préfet a fait son travail et la
justice regarde. Voilà,
il a pas été condamné.
Ah mais non, mais il est même pas mise
en examen. C'est l'enquête n'est pas
ouverte.
C'est c'est un c'est une très longue
sieste au niveau du tribunal, vous
voyez. Mais c'est une sieste qui va nous
coûter à nous parce qu'on est en train
de développer le discours que en fait et
je ne l'invente pas. C'était les titres
de de d'une certaine presse pour dire la
corruption à Mayotte. Donc pour en fait
sous-entendre qu'il ne faut pas faire la
reconstruction par c'est un territoire
corrompu. Faut pas faire la
reconstruction. Moi, j'ai jamais entendu
dans les discours quand il y avait des
problèmes de corruption à Marseille, à
Lyon ou à Paris, on va vous couper
l'eau.
10.
Non mais jamais,
jamais. Mais mais à Mayotte, c'est
opportunement un bon argument.
Et la partie qui est la plus scandaleuse
dans cette
dans cette corruption, c'est que la
corruption à Mayotte est vraiment à une
échelle minime. Je l'excuse pas du tout
mais comme on a très peu d'argent
qui arrive sur l'île, elle nous coûte
très cher cette corruption parce qu'on a
désespérément besoin du moindre centime.
C'est quoi vos recours ? Donc donc quand
on est avec des coupures d'eau, ben
c'est c'est 50 millions qui s'est
évaporé du syndicat des eaux. C'est 50
millions d'euros qui s'est évaporé du
syndicat des eaux. Quand vous connaissez
les autres budgets des syndicats des
eau, c'est rien. C'est une goutte sans
mauvais jeu de mot.
Sauf queen fait c'est ce qui participe
au fait que nous on n pas d'eau parce
qu'on a tellement peu d'investissements
que ces 50 millions, ils étaient vitaux
et que donc votre servante elle va et
elle supplie les autorités de mettre
sous enquête le parquet national le le
que le parquet national financier
s'empare du syndicat des autres de
Mayotte pour les empêcher de sévir et
qu'on arrête de me servir au niveau du
gouvernement. Ah mais non, on va pas te
financer l'eau à Mayotte, tu as vu, ils
sont tous corrompus.
Mais en fait,
agissez,
agissez.
Moi, je je ne peux pas faire plus que
dénoncer et demander à la population à
aux autorité d'agir. Mais en fait, la
passivité
des autorités à cet égard, elle pose
question comme elle pose question sur la
reconstruction des bidonville, comme
elle pose question sur le fait de
laisser entrer les bateaux avec les
migrants. c'est que au bout d'un moment,
vous pouvez pas regarder la situation de
Mayotte se dégrader à une telle vitesse
et à une telle ampleur avec une inertie
et un pourrissement sans vous dire ça
devient volontaire.
C'est que même pour nous les plus
français des Français qui sommes battus
pour le rester, qui sommes en train
d'être envahi pour pour nous arracher
notre terre, on regarde Paris tout en
ayant conscience du monde qui se
disloque que Paris c'est vraiment c'est
la zizanie la plus absolue. Mais en se
disant il y a quelque chose là de
fondamental où en fait ils ont perdu euh
le nord. C'est-à-dire que moi, les
Françaises et les Français, mes
compatriotes, ils ont donné 50 millions
d'euros à la fondation de France pour
aider les Mauris et les Maoré.
sans appel de la fondation de France,
par solidarité, par compassion pendant
Noël, des milliers de fonctionnaires,
d'électriciens, de pompiers, de
gendarmes, de policiers, d'infirmiers,
de médecins qui sont venus pour qui ont
quitté leur famille pendant Noël pour
nous porter secours.
La France n'a pas abandonné Mayotte dans
le sens où nos compatriotes ne nous ni
pas notre caractère d'être français.
C'est l'État qui ne fait rien. C'est les
gouvernements successifs. Parce que là,
en un an, trois et même musique, pas un
sous pour Mayotte. Donc on fait deux
loin Mayotte parce que vous avez jamais
entendu autant parler de Mayotte au
parlement au point que mes collègues me
disent ça commence à nous fatiguer. Donc
sympathique parce que ça fait 40 ans
qu'ils ont jamais entendu parler. Mais
bon, c'est pas grave. Mais là, la
première c'était première loi Mayot,
c'est une loi technique qui a permis au
gouvernement Bairou de gagner du temps
et de faire passer son budget
rectificatif, son budget pardon en
février sans mettre un sous sur la
reconstruction pour dire "J'ai besoin de
quelques semaines pour faire le tour de
mes 375 km² pour chiffrer le coût de la
reconstruction après le budget."
Ça c'est de l'intelligence politique,
c'est d'une finesse. Il faut voir le
Manuel Vals à l'œuvre pour comprendre.
C'est un métier.
C'est un métier et une leçon que Mayotte
paye très cher. Donc après c'était ah
ben on va se gargariser du du de
l'immigration et on utilise Mayotte pour
la question du droit du sol.
Et donc là, on se gargarise tout en
laissant les bidonville se reconstruire.
Là aussi, grosse grosse communication.
Et puis ensuite, on fait la loi de
programmation
à la fin de l'année parlementaire. Tout
le monde est sur les genoux.
Et là c'est vraiment là c'est
l'apothéose parce que c'est reprendre
des projets qui entre 10 20 ans 5 ans
tous antérieurs au cyclone
les rabiller pour les mettre dans la loi
de programmation
faire de la com en disant on met 4
milliards à Mayotte et c'est de la
programmation ce n'est pas budgé
et comme ça c'est ben comme ça vous avez
gagné 1 an d'économie sur le territoire
le plus pauvre de France est dévasté par
un cyclone 1 an.
Voilà.
Et ensuite et ensuite vous vous
retrouvez en septembre avec une
discussion à l'Élysée
évoquant l'avenir institutionnel des
outres mères.
Et là, on est avec deux territoires qui
disent nous autonomie et indépendance.
La Réunion et Mayotte qui disent non.
président de la République Emmanuel Vals
qui mettent sur la table qu'est-ce qui
vous intéresse dans les évolutions
constitutionnelles pour vous faire
avancer vers d'autonomie, réfléchir à
l'indépendance
qu' pousse
septembre 2025
c'estd que si je devais me faire la
voquer du diable
il bossent pour peut-être une autre
puissance ces gens-là s'ils veulent vous
larier en plein milieu de l'océan et qui
vous pousse
il vous pousse à l'indépendance il vous
pous Je sais pas je sais pas pour qui il
bosse mais je pense que pour l'intérêt
national non.
Ou alors dans la revue nationale
stratégique, on a revu fondamentalement
ce qu'est la France et la France n'est
que l'hexagone. Et là il y a urgence à
ce que les Français en aient conscience
parce que parce que je crois que tout le
monde a pas compris ce que ça
signifiait.
La France sans ses outreemers, c'est
rien. C'est une poussière
en terme de zone de pêche, en terme
d'exploitation de de
Ah ben oui, le discours habituel sur les
outresemes, c'est toujours qu'on est des
poids morts. Enfin bon, c'est c'est
charmant, hein. Je rappelle que bon,
c'est tout le poids diplomatique qui
permet à la France d'être au Conseil de
sécurité, qui permet à la France d'être
dans tous les cercles régionaux mondiaux
parce que elle a un territoire dans
chaque région. Donc c'est c'est ce qui
fait que la France est aussi importante
diplomatiquement. C'est effectivement
euh pour les zones économiques exclusive
puisque'autour de chaque territoire
insulaire, on a les eaux qui sont
autour. C'est monayer des droits de
pêche, c'est développer toute l'économie
bleue, ça c'est le terme un petit peu
sympathique, mais ça va être euh le
minerai sous-marin qui sont les nodules
qui sont les métaux rares qui seront qui
qui seront extrêmement importants, qu'il
y a dans votre téléphone portable,
voilà, qui sont la ressource de demain.
Euh évidemment, les hydrocarbures,
évidemment les les métaux précieux comme
il peut y avoir en Guyane. a toute la
biodiversité
qui est extrêmement importante, qui
permet euh à Paris d'être sur des
discussions qui que l'hexagone ne
pourrait pas avoir. Je veux dire, vous
êtes pas vous avez pas le président de
la République qui a invité pour un
sommet en Amérique du Sud parce qu'il
est beau gosse, c'est parce qu'il y a la
Guyane et les Antilles comme on fait
partie des des espaces caraïbéens pour
les discussions régionales. Voyez ? Et
donc cette logique là qui est de voir
les outresemères uniquement sous un
prisme territorial et pas sous un prisme
humain
de ne pas comprendre que la richesse
parce que là je vous parle de de biens
matériel mais en fait la richesse
immatérielle des outres mères elle est
énorme dans la contribution à notre
culture à ce que nous sommes, à notre
richesse humaine, à notre richesse
patrimoniale que ce soit culturel, que
ce soit culinaire, que ce soit sur nos
notre habillement, sur notre imaginaire
collectif, évidemment que les
outresemères constituent une part très
importante de l'identité française. Le
problème c'est que dans le choix qui est
opéré dans cette France qui doute en
fait, elle n'assume pas son passé
colonial et les outremères, c'est les
confétis de ce passé colonial. C'est
pour ça que tout à l'heure, j'ai parlé
d'un dernier épisode qui est très
invisible dans l'hexagone de cette
décolonisation avec la discussion qui
est actuellement en cours dans les
outres mères, la plupart d'entre eux, de
se dire autonomie ou indépendance et
avec les deux gaulois de l'Ossau Indien,
la Réunion et Mayotte
où où en fait on comprend que Paris est
quand même un peu gêné aux entournures
et alors c'est d'autant plus paradoxal
que d'abord ça remet en cause tout le
discours de vous êtes français.
Juste qu'on ait un peu l'honnêteté de la
chose parce que si vous dites ben en
fait vous êtes français mais mais
peut-être pas
ou alors c'était un CDD, c'est quand
même extrêmement grave.
Ça remet en cause et c'est pour ça que
c'est une question qui est complexe et
difficile pour les autorités. Ça remet
en cause tout le discours sur les
bienfaits de la colonisation.
C'est la colonisation et l'histoire de
la France avec ses outreemères, c'est un
solilo
c'est l'hexagone qui parle à ces
territoires lointains et qui se raconte
ces territoires lointains.
Aujourd'hui, avec les nouvelles
technologies, avec aussi l'immigration,
les migration et les et les voyages des
ultramarins,
bah les ultramarins se regardent entre
eux et on découvre des points communs.
Nous entre ultramarins, Mayotte et la
Guyane par exemple sont deux territoires
très semblables par rapport au défis
auquels on fait face d'immigration, de
mauvais traitement par Paris,
de de défis et et d'une rage de vouloir
exister.
avec des singularités très fortes mais
des similarités. Et en même temps, il y
a euh pour les hexagonaux un miroir qui
est très violent en fait de se dire on
était convaincu que ça allait, qu'on
était un pays puissant qui avait sorti
ces territoires de la pauvreté et en
fait ben pour certains
un ce n'est pas du tout le cas et de
deux les voisins en fait ont eux réussi.
C'est c'est intéressant le parallèle
avec le CDD. Est-ce que euh est-ce qu'on
a une gestion d'État avec un on dirait
un capitaine d'industrie qui voit son
business se rétrécir de plus en plus de
dettes, des problèmes un peu partout et
qui décide en fait de retirer la mer, de
retirer ses biss, de faire une débacle,
de faire un repli stratégique sur
l'hexagone parce que il a plus assez
d'argent ou parce que il ne comprend pas
l'avantage des territoires ultramarins
en terme de ressources, de peuple. de de
zone de contrôle géopolitique,
géostratégique.
Est-ce que c'est les crétins ou est-ce
qu'ils ont décidé de vous abandonner
parce que la France est en train de
crever ?
Parce que l'un n'empêche pas l'autre.
Non mais pardon, mais en fait c'est pas
c'est pas mutuellement exclusif. Je
pense que parce que ce qui est
sous-entendu, c'est que ce sera une
décision du président Macron. Moi je
pense que c'est un délitement qui est
sur plusieurs présidences et que lui
récolte le fruit vraiment mur et pourri.
Voilà, on va dire ça comme ça sur la
question ultramarine parce que il y a
quand même à Paris une méconnaissance et
un effondrement de la connaissance
connaissance des questions ultramarines
qui s'expliquent avec la fin du service
militaire. Il y a de moins en moins
d'hexagonaux qui sont partis en outreem.
Non non non, je m'explique. Il y a il y
a de moins en moins d'hexagonaux qui
connaissent les ultramarins et qui sont
allés en outreem ce que le service
militaire en fait imposait. Ça c'est
très important.
Donc ça c'est depuis le service
militaire. les les
ultramarins vont moins dans l'hexagone
pour leur services et inversement il y a
moins d'hexagonaux dans les outresem.
Donc il y a une méconnaissance, le lien
s'est discendu dans les partis avec
l'effondrement des partis en fait il y a
politique, il y a moins d'ultraarin et
donc il y a plus de mémoire
institutionnelle au sein des partis
politiques pour avoir une vision
politique des outresem et ça ça se
traduit dans le fait que vous avez une
absence de discours dans la plupart des
partis politiques. Soit ils sont sur une
lecture qui est complètement hors sol,
mais alors et puis c'est le même le même
can pour tous les territoire donc
complètement
décorrélé de la réalité locale qui est
chaque territoire ultramarin a une
histoire singulière et des et des
attentes singulières et donc il projette
soit comment dire vous êtes avec par
exemple pour LFI ou pour la le RN deux
parties qui sont très offensives sur les
Mè qui ont parfaitement compris les
enjeux et qui développent et qui
prospèrent suralise
qui prospère sur des déficiences réelles
et un manque de discours politique au
sens noble construit pour dire qu'est-ce
qu'on fait de ces territoires ? La
question elle est pas est-ce qu'on est
d'accord ou pas avec c'est au moins
qu'on se pose la question. Enfin moi je
suis même plus
connaissez notre avis sur les partis
politique pour nous c'est les touristes.
Il y a bien un fonctionnaire d'état, il
y a bien un militaire.
Mais c'est le même sujet qui va
c'est le même sujet dans les dans les
ministères. C'est-à-dire chez les
ministères, il y a quasiment plus de
fonctionnaires qui connaissent les
outresemères et donc ils sont Mais oui,
parce qu'en fait l'enveloppe a été
réduite et total, ils ont une perte de
mémoire sur les dossiers donc ils sont
très peu à maîtriser les dossiers et
donc on se retrouve avec les mêmes
interlocuteurs qui multiplient les mêmes
conneries depuis 30 ans et qui se
remettent jamais en question.
Excusez-moi de dire les choses
vulgairement mais en fait problématique
de cap économique, de cap géopolitique
géostratégique,
ressources,
zone de pêche, zone d'influence trois
points simples ressources donc énergie
attention l'ingénieur du son il va
gueuler pour
Oui, pardon. Euh
euh donc ressources euh on dit que la
guerre avec les les popof, c'est une
guerre énergétique. On voit bien la
guerre énergétique que ça les
répercussions de cette guerre sur nos
intrans, sur notre prix de
l'électricité, sur notre plein d'essence
et j'en passe même si ça fait rentrer de
la TVA et j'en passe et j'en passe.
N'importe quelle
personne qui joue à des jeux de
stratégie basé sur l'énergie, c'est que
quand on a quelques petites bases à côté
de ressources de gaz, de mines, de
ressources alimentaires,
ça peut toujours servir
en terme de construire, de de de d'avoir
une influence.
Il y a plus ça dans nos ministères. Moi,
je voudrais parce que je suis maillotte
centrique, je vais vous parler de mon
voisinage.
Donc j'ai l'échor, petite dictature
sympathique qui est en train de se
transformer, bon hostile, qui revendique
un territoire français à qui on déroule
le tapis rouge. Madagascar,
j'ai la grande île Madagascar
qui vient en quelques semaines d'avoir
une petite révolution Genz avec une
prise de pouvoir des généraux qui
viennent d'aller envoyer le président de
leur assemblée à Moscou
et d'avoir une offre de service des
Chinois et pour lesquels le président de
la commission des affaires étrangères
vient d'aller expliquer aux généraux qui
à qui chez qui on Je viens de découvrir
et c'était aux informations hier
300 kg d'one dans le bureau
et qui réclame au chef d'entreprise à
Madagascar de leur payer cash dans la
semaine 5 millions d'euros parce que les
bonhommes pensent qu'ils vont pas rester
longtemps au pouvoir. D'habitude les les
dirigeants malgaches saignent mais 1
million par mois. Là il demandent 5
millions pour la semaine parce qu'il se
dit on sait pas combien de temps on
reste. Donc les mecs sont à un autre
niveau de corruption. Ils ont vraiment
puis c'est tu pêches tu payes ou la tôle
ou la calche hein. C'est plata ou plomo
version malgache, ils sont vraiment
c'est pas des comiques. Donc eux on est
à Madagascar
à 300 km de Mayotte et de la Réunion
dans un scénario à la malienne en
accéléré
en accéléré. Il y a déjà les bonhommes
de Wagner, il y a déjà eu et s'est avéré
trafic de de d'or, trafic de métaux
précieux, trafic de bois précieux et
comment dire une offre de service de
Moscou qui est tout à fait évidente et
puis qui qui je veux dire ils ont déjà
influencé les élections précédemment
mais là ils sont vraiment en train de
mettre le le la main sur le pactol parce
que parce que la grande île c'est
vraiment c'est Madagascar, je parle de
Grandî Paris que Madagascar c'est la
France plus le Bénéluxe plus la
péninsule ibérique. C'est immense
Madagascar et c'est vraiment c'est une
île stratégique richissime richissime
qui est pauvre mais qui est extrêmement
riche. Et donc Paris qui a eu une
décolonisation qui fait passer la garde
d'Algérie pour du pipicha tellement que
c'était violent. Les massacres qu'ont
commis les Français à Madagascar sont
d'une violence inouie. un passif
historique qui n'a pas du tout été réglé
avec un passif euh territorial. Ce sont
euh les îles éparses que les com que les
malgaches revendiquent et que Paris euh
garde. Sont les fameuses euh terres
australes
qui nous permettent d'aller faire de la
surveillance
au niveau du du pôle sud. Euh voilà,
voyez, parce que quand je discute avec
le chef d'étatmajor, son prédécesseur et
que je lui explique qu'il va mieux
protéger Mayotte que d'aller chasser les
pingouin, comprenez que ils le prennent
un peu mal. Mais moi, je prends très mal
en fait cette obsession à dire "On va
sur les tafs au lieu de faire le taf à
Mayotte." Voyez ça ça devient un peu
gênant protéger une frontière. Quand
j'explique au chef d'étatmajor que le
mot défense a un sens, ça devient euh
extrêmement frustrant et très
désagréable pour lui comme pour moi.
Terra maot, il y a la DGSI qui se
balade, il y a la DGSE qui se balade
certainement. Mais enfin, il y en a
d'autres. Non, non, mais il y en a
d'autres. Moi mon sujet c'est pas
Il y en a d'autres. Mais est-ce qu'ils
vont se balader ? Faire l'inter.
Entendez ce que je dis. Il y en a
d'autres.
Oui. De d'autres de pas de chez nous. Ah
ouais. Et on les repère comment ? Ah bah
ils sont blancs.
Ah pas que
nous nous pour intercepter. Non non non
mais l'océan Indien c'est repères de
Nidespion hein juste parce que Non non
non mais je je vais expliquer je vais
expliquer
c'est vous avez Madagascar donc là le
génie de notre diplomatie dont vous
soulignez l'intelligence c'est c'est
vraiment c'est là là on voit que fait
Paris on va aider à exfiltrer le
président qui vient de se faire virer
donc on met en danger tous les
ressortissants
français qu'il y a à Madagascar et les
binationaux et ils sont très nombreux
mais surtout On a envoyé un message
à mon petit Azali à côté que en cas de
problème
Paris viendra à ton secours. C'est ça ce
qui est lu à côté. Et là je rappelle OK,
je dis alors je vous rappelle que la
dernière fois que Paris s'est ingéré
dans les affaires comoriennes, on a eu
la population comorienne de Mayotte qui
a fait une chasse au blanc, c'était en
2008 et que ça a été extrêmement
violent. et à l'époque, ils étaient pas
quasi majoritaires.
Donc vous aurez l'intelligence, je vais
pas discuter de vos amitiés
mais de vous poser deux trois questions.
Merci madame la députée. C'était un
angle mort de notre réflexion.
Je ne peux pas l'inventer.
Donc ça c'est le génie à l'œuvre. Ça
c'est Madagascar.
À côté, pas très loin, c'est la
Tanzanie.
La Tanzanie. Non la Tanzani qu'il a
parce que pour nous c'est voisins très
très proches hein. C'est plus proche que
le Kenya. La Tanzanie, c'est des
dizaines de morts. Ils sont en
instabilité très forte avec des émeutes
extrêmement violentes. Jenzy alors eux
bah les pauvres génération Z comme ce
qui s'est passé au Népal, euh en
Indonésie, maintenant à Madagascar, ce
qui a tenté de se passer à au Maroc et
qui est actuellement en cours en
Tanzanie. Bon, elle elle a elle a pas
tergiversé hein, la première ministre,
elle a coupé euh internet. sont comme ça
Jenzy sans le téléphone portable, ils
sont en train de les massacrer. Voilà,
donc ça c'est fait et puis ça continue.
Et je veux dire, nous on est dans un
foyer d'instabilité qui se dégrade à une
vitesse. C'est nos voisins immédiats.
Tous sont à quelques heures de bateau et
moins d'une heure en avion.
Et on a on a
le chef d'étatmajor qui dit
"Préparez-vous au sacrifice de vos
enfants." Ben, nos enfants sont déjà
sacrifiés. hein,
ils vont vont ils vont à l'école
attaqués par des comoriens, ils vont
sous protection avec les gendarmes qui
sont déployés avec des gaz lacrymogènes
pour protéger les enfants à Mayotte pour
aller à l'école. Il y a des combats
quotidiens parce que ça a repris et donc
je ne sais pas pourquoi est-ce que les
uns et les autres parlent d'une
hypothèque. Elle est déjà à l'œuvre la
guerre. Elle est déjà à l'œuvre. C'est
un combat hybride mais c'est déjà le
cas. et que quand vous avez les Russes
qui envoient un bateau qui est d'abord
sous drapeau comorien puis en plus en
ensuite sous bateau béninois au large de
Saint-Nazer, vous avez compris que les
Russes sont pas là pour plaisanter,
que quand vous avez la flotte fantôme
comorienne qui va aller faire du trafic
de de de pétrole russe,
j'ai du mal à comprendre la cohérence au
niveau du quer ménager ce bonhomme. Vous
voyez
peut-être pas au courant.
Voilà, il y a un défaut d'information.
Il faut qu'il écoute viiew plus souvent
et que je remetteur
du son. Il va brailler sinon.
Tu bra ingénieur du son. Ça va tout va
bien. Ma question concernant le
renseignement de terrain sur Mayotte sur
où est-ce qu'on prend l'information des
indiques, où est-ce qu'on prend
l'information auprès des commerces ?
Pas la bonne interlocutrice pour ça.
J'espère bien.
Mais non, moi je je ne fais pas du
renseignement.
D'accord. Est-ce que il y a des services
de renseignement, permettez-moi
l'expression, qui se sortent les doigts
du fus pour essayer de faire de
l'incontreingérence ? Est-ce que il y a
par exemple
des gens qui viennent vous voir en
disant voilà, est-ce que vous savez pas
que lui est-ce qu'il pourrait nous
informer ou des commerçants ou quoi que
ce soit ? Il y a bien une politique de
contre-ingérence française. Il nous
bassine à longueur de journée avec la
guerri hybride. Vous comprenez les
médias, vous comprenez la militarisation
des flux migratoires. Mais dans les
faits, quels sont les
Mais je pense je pense qu'en fait ce que
ce que ce que vous
la manifestation la plus évidente de la
guerre hybride, c'est la désinformation
sur les réseaux sociaux. OK ? C'est Lia,
c'est c'est les deux théâtres sur
lequels c'est vraiment déployé au
maximum, c'est la Nouvelle-Calédonie et
Mayotte. Mais vous voyez
le le
l'impuissance complète de Paris, c'estàd
leur seule réponse. Mais non, ils ont en
Nouvelle mais non mais en
Nouvelle-Calédonie, ils ont dit on va
essayer de de fermer TikTok,
c'est tout. Et la réponse ici ou
atteinte aux libertés.
Non mais euh Choupi, ils sont en train
de d'appeler à l'insurrection.
Ils se donnent rendez-vous sur les
réseaux sociaux pour aller cramer du
blanc. Tu c'est la liberté absolue. Je
veux dire, nous on est à Mayotte. Je
fais passer des alertes au gouvernement,
aux représentants du gouvernement à
Mayotte et aux autorités qui découvrent
sur Facebook les bandes qui se donnent
rendez-vous pour aller cramer un lycée.
Ça c'était la semaine dernière. Bah il
se il se bouge mais enfin je veux dire
ils se bougent, ils font les enquêtes,
ils procèdent aux arrestations et cetera
mais sur le fond quand on dit qu'elle
est informationnelle c'est ça participe
d'un climat de terreur qui est
profondément destructeur. Les gens
partent, les magasins ferment, vous
n'allez vous n'envoyez pas vos enfants à
l'école, vous vivez dans la terreur. Une
vraie terreur, c'est pas une terreur
imaginaire. Vous êtes ce qui s'est passé
il y a il y a 2 semaines euh dans
Mamutzu à Kaeni au lycée des Lumières.
C'est une cité scolaire avec des
milliers d'élèves qui étaient attaqués
par des bandes de jeunes et des
centaines de forces de l'ordre non avec
des centaines de forces de l'ordre qui
ont été mobilisées au gaz lacrymogène
pour aller évacuer des milliers
d'enfants attaqués à la machette avec
des gamins qui étaient avec des cailloux
et vas-y. C'était le festival. Ça a duré
pendant des heures. Les parents sont
profondés les parents, les enseignants,
tout le monde est profondément
traumatisé. Mais
mais les forces de l'ordre, elles sont
pas elles peuvent pas avoir l'ordre de
tirer à balle réelle, de tirer avec son
des gamins du compliqué. Ouais,
parce que la lâcheté de de des
adversaires à Mayotte,
c'est d'envoyer des millions,
c'est d'envoyer des enfants.
Quand on entend le débat ici là sur les
narcos, pensez pas que
les mecs ils ont pas inventé l'eau
chaude, hein.
Puis c'est c'est c'est la dislocation du
monde dans lequel on vit, elle laisse
tout le monde dans une terreur qui est
profonde parce qu'en fait on se dit on
s'est réfugie où
vous avez la violence qui vient sur le
pas de votre porte. Sarme
de plus en plus
avec quel type d'arme ? Plus à poudre ou
plus ça ? Je je veux pas savoir.
Moi moi aussi j'ai un problème de santé
mentale. Moi je je peux pas Non mais moi
je peux pas juste fonctionner avec un
niveau de d'anxiété. Mon mon job c'est
de m'inquiéter pour ma population. Mon
angoisse quand j'ai été élu de me dire
s'il y a une catastrophe elle sera
stratosphérique. La catastrophe est
arrivée. Elle est stratosphérique. S'il
y a une catastrophe stratosphérique,
l'État sera aux fraises. Il est plus aux
fraises. Il est je sais pas où. Je veux
dire c'est c'est affreux. Moi tout à
l'heure avant de venir pour l'interview,
j'étais en j'étais sur WhatsApp avec une
m si si je vous lis le message, il est
affreux qui me dit voilà on est dans une
zone, on est pris entre les bandes de
migrants et les deux bandes qui se
tapent dessus. On estage. Je ne peux pas
témoigner parce que j'ai peur. Je vais
lui dire je vais te mettre en lien avec
la personne la plus influence au niveau
de de la police nationale à Mayotte.
Est-ce que tu penses que ma sécurité est
garantie ? Il y a mes neveux, il y a ma
famille, il y a c'est ça mon travail.
Est-ce qu'il faut envoyer l'armée ?
Bah on a on a déjà une partie de
l'armée. Quand je dis envoyer l'armée,
c'est-à-dire envoyer un demi bataillon
et aller choper tous les OQTF, aller
choper toutes les armes, aller choper
tout le monde.
Nous, c'est ce qu'on a demandé avec
Wembouchou et on a on a obtenu, ça a été
interrompu parce que les événements ont
éclaté en Nouvelle-Calédonie. Donc
Wembouchou a été interrompu. Wembouchou
a eu le mérite et moi je demande à
Wambouchou 2 de renverser le rapport de
force et de faire comprendre
pour ceux qui n'ont pas suivi
pardon c'était l'opération où en fait le
ministère de l'intérieur a envoyé des
escadrons et l'armée et a commencé à
procéder massivement à des arrestations
à destruction des bidonvillees et à
reprendre regagner le terrain perdu par
la République que personne au niveau
politique national n'a assumé hein.
J'étais la seule élue à à assumer ça et
je le revendique
à Paris toute la gauche. Pétage de câble
total. Oui, mais vous vous rendez compte
? Oui. Oui. Je me rends bien compte que
en fait à un moment la peur doit changer
de camp. que ce n'est pas normal que nos
enfants aillent à l'école sous
protection de la gendarmerie, que ce
n'est pas normal qu'on caillasse des des
soignant, que on ne vit plus normalement
et que oui, il faut agir. Euh le
problème, c'est que la gauche s'est
déplacé sur place ou pas ? Oui, j'ai eu
monsieur Ruffin qui qui est descendu de
l'avion en disant "Je viens de parler
avec une comorienne euh elle est très
très attachée à Mayotte, elle souffre
puis tu te dis bon c'est foutu lui
maillotte,
il vient il vient vient pour discuter
avec euh
il a été se baladé dans les bonville.
Est-ce qu'il a été loué une Opel Corsa
tout seul sans sa prétorienne ? Il est
descendu avec son Opel Corsa
pour prendre la route normale ? Est-ce
qu'il est tombé sur un barrage ? Et là
il a fa poser la question.
Je lui poserai la question.
Non mais c'est c'est
voilà si vous voulez la question
militaire. Non mais la question
militaire en fait elle est très
importante parce que nous on demande
l'installation d'une balle de la marine
nationale
pour protéger notre lagon qu'on
construise une défense en mer qui soit
cohérente. La question qui est posée par
Mayotte, c'est pour ça que j'insiste
mais vraiment je pense qu'il faut
comprendre le défi que pose Mayotte.
C'est pas un défi local, c'est un défi
national et international.
Le défi que pose Mayotte, c'est est-ce
que la frontière en mer existe ?
Parce que c'est
c'est pas c'est pas une question
ésotérique. C'est la question que posent
les Chinois
quand ils créent des îles et qu'ils vont
en mer de Chine. C'est la question que
posent les Grecs et les Italiens quand
ils font du pushback en Méditerranée.
Et donc nous, pseudo puissance maritime
qui défendons une frontière dans la
manche
avons décidé l'impuissance à Mayotte.
Voilà,
c'est on l'a décidé où on peut plus
faire en fait.
Ah moi je sais pas. Moi ça c'est un
discours que je peux pas entendre. On
fait 375 km², on est 300000. Si on sait
pas gérer Mayotte, faut pas gérer la
France. Faut arrêter. Faut changer de
métier, faut faut changer de crèmerie,
faut faut franchement faut capituler.
Puis là, on remballe. Non, franchement,
si on est dépassé par un petit caillou
comme ça, faut quitter là les palais, la
République, l'ONU, l'Union européenne et
puis aller faire ses fraises, cultiver
son jardin et bouffer bio parce que là
vraiment là, c'est plus de la femelette
hein, c'est qu'on a capitulé.
Mais c'est pas le cas. Non,
c'est qu'on veut pas. Mais c'est mais
c'est pas qu'on peut pas, c'est qu'on
veut pas.
Pardon hein, mais je ça je peux pas
entendre. On ne peut pas. Si vous allez
me dire si on veut si si vous Mais non
mais 375 km² je de quoi on parle ? C'est
ridicule.
J'arrive pas à bouger un point de à côté
d'une maternelle. On on déplace l'école
maternelle.
Faut déplacer Mayotte. Il y a que quel
question.
Alors je viens je viens à la prochaine
question. Je viens. Je Non, non mais
déconnez pas
Choupinette. Écoute-moi, il y a a Shida
qui a déjà déplacé beaucoup de choses.
Qu'est-ce que vous voulez nous infliger
de plus ?
Donc là, on va faire une expérience de
pensée. Vous moins
penser c'est déjà beaucoup. J'écoute.
Et on se retrouve me déconcentrez pas,
attention,
on va pousser on va on va pousser le
vis. ingérence étrangère qui foutent le
feu à Mayotte, un autre un autre cyclone
qui passe, une épidémie qui débarque euh
euh euh un flux migratoire militarisé
par les Russes, les Azerbaïdjanis, euh
les Chinois, Pierre-Paul ou Jacques, euh
n'importe quoi. Un gros conflit qui
débarque en Afrique qui vous fait
ramener plein de personnes par chez
vous, par chez nous en fait.
Est-ce que vous avez discuté le fait que
Paris va peut-être évacuer les maorettes
de chez eux parce que ça va devenir
tellement un furoncle
à gérer qu'ils vont préférer vous
déplacer et faire des camps de Maoré à
Paris par - 5 en bordure du périphérique
plutôt que d'aller protéger l'île.
C'est notre notre cauchemar.
Pour moi, c'est inenvisageable, mais
c'est évidemment la question qui se
pose.
Et on pourra pas nous arracher à notre
terre.
Moi, j'ai toujours dit on mourra mais on
mourra debout.
Nous, on renoncera pas à Mayotte.
C'est la terre de nos ancêtres, c'est la
terre de nos enfants, nos petits-enfants
et elle sera française.
On mourra comme les Français chez nous.
Alors, on viendra mourir chez vous.
C'est pour ça que je pense qu'il y a il
y a un refus de regarder le réel à Paris
qui nous condamne tous collectivement
parce que ce manque de lucidité, ce
manque d'humilité,
ce manque de capacité à se remettre en
question nous met en danger tous.
Quand vous avez le chef d'étatmajor qui
alerte sur la situation,
ce qui la réaction qu'il a qu'il reçoit,
c'est en fait la réaction de la classe
politique au fait que le président de la
République a instrumentalisé la guerre
en Ukraine pour fausser la campagne de
2022. Et donc ce qui est vrai
aujourd'hui n'est plus audible.
Il a démonétisé, tellement vidé
que quand il y a l'avertissement, on ne
l'entend plus parce qu'on entend juste
l'orateur. On se dit c'est faux.
Alors que moi j'en suis convaincu,
une bonne partie de celles et ceux qui
connaissent ce sujet savent que
effectivement on s'achemine vers un
affrontement que pour les les un
affrontement direct mais que pour les
territoires ultramarins, on le subit
déjà pour certains.
La déstabilisation que c'est une guerre
hybride mais çaen est une quand même.
Et donc
la
radicalité que vous pouvez percevoir
quand je dis "On mourra debout",
je suis fille et sort de militaire.
Oui, le sacrifice ultime pour le drapeau
n'est pas une abstraction, mais ce n'est
pas un souhait.
C'est aussi savoir ce pourquoi on est
là.
Euh être français, c'est euh être libre.
C'est ce pourquoi Mayotte a voulu rester
française.
Euh et ça induit des sacrifices. Ce que
nous n'acceptons plus à Mayotte en tout
cas, c'est l'injustice du traitement qui
nous est réservé.
Quand nos enfants servent le drapeau,
quand certains meurent pour la patrie,
quand nos compatriotes
nous voi comme des leurs, le fait que
l'État continue une discrimination
systémique, c'est insupportable.
Quand il y a 2 semaines, je suis dans
l'hémicycle et je dis sur le débat des
retraites,
les retraites à Mayotte sont en moyenne
entre 120 et 150 € par mois.
Euh pour mettre les retraites au niveau
juste du seuil de pauvreté à Mayotte, ça
coûterait 12 millions d'euros. Et la
caisse de retraite de Mayotte est
excédentaire. Elle envoie chaque année
61 millions d'euros à l'hexagone.
61 millions d'euros à Paris
et Paris refuse de faire la réforme de
12 millions pour donner un peu de
dignité à nos vieux.
Et moi, je vais vous dire ce que j'en
pense, hein. Paris fait comme avec les
tirailleurs sénégalais, ils attendent
qu'il crèvent.
Donc
ça demande beaucoup de patience
mais nous on a atteint nos limites.
Et ce que les gens comprennent pas c'est
que à Mayotte, on a plus rien à perdre
parce qu'on a tout perdu.
On a tout perdu.
Donc les Simagr à Paris,
les états d'âme, les élections, les je
sais pas quoi,
les débats sur la résilience, vous allez
perdre vos enfants. Oui. Oui.
Viens quand tu auras pas d'eau, pas de
téléphone, pas d'électricité pendant des
semaines,
nous expliquer à nous ce que c'est que
la résilience. C'est un terme qu'on peut
plus entendre
et que et que le sujet c'est pas je ne
remet pas du tout en question
l'effort. C'est-à-dire que nous on a vu
il y a un gendarme qui a perdu la vie
qui était qui était un peu âgé en je le
dis pas mais je crois qu'un cas génère
il a pas supporté la chaleur. Il était
en train de porter secours sur les
hauteurs dans les bidonvillees. Il a pas
supporté la chaleur, il a fait un arrêt
cardiaque. Les personnes qui sont venues
à Mayotte pour nous aider pendant Chido,
elles sont venues pendant les fêtes de
Noël. Elles ont quitté leur famille pour
venir sur des camps, sur des lits de
camp avec pas d'eau, pas d'électricité,
rien pour nous aider.
Le sujet c'est c'est de dire la
reconstruction, ce que pose l'absence de
reconstruction, c'est l'absence de
dignité.
c'est de dire vous allez on va vous
reconstruire une île en container
puis vous allez vous satisfaire de
projet recyclé.
En fait, il y a pas d'ambition pour le
terrain. Il y en a aucune.
C'est de dire oui pour la survie mais
vous sortirez jamais de la survie.
Et ça c'est une rupture profonde du
pacte républicain.
C'est c'est un un rejet et l'écho que ça
a dépasse bien largement Mayotte. C'est
pour ça que c'est aussi investi
politiquement et la classe politique a
beaucoup de mal à s'en emparer alors que
les Français ont parfaitement compris ce
qui se jouait à Mayotte. Parfaitement
quand vous leur demandez. Mais les gens
ils comprennent très bien parce qu'ils
s'identifient. Ils se disent "Mais
ils sont des contribuables, ils sont des
électeurs, ils sont des citoyens,
ils sont français.
On a dit que la race n'existait pas, la
couleur de peau n'existait pas. Donc en
fait pourquoi est-ce qu'ils auraient
moins de droits que moi ? Pourquoi
est-ce que seulement la moitié des
prestations sociales existe à Mayotte et
quand elles existent, elles sont à la
moitié du montant national ?
alors que l'imposition est la même parce
que sinon ce serait pas drôle.
Bah oui. Pourquoi est-ce que on va
trouver toutes sortes de raisons pour
pas appliquer les lois mais
se trouver des excuses, je peux pas, je
sais pas, piquenique poney piscine et
que sais-je encore là ? Est-ce que quand
même tu bon pas de diffamation ni quoi
que ce soit mais ça c'est les conditions
de sécurité non mais le ministre pas de
dénigrement c'est pas du dénigrement
c'est du constat ministre de l'autre mer
qu'est-ce qui
l'ancien ministre
oui parce que nos prières ont enfin été
exaucé
en fait qu'est-ce qui s'est passé c'est
quand même c'est extraordinaire le le
ministre Emmanuel Vals illustre que ce
que j'ai expliqué expliqué tout à
l'heure les questions ultramarines sont
tellement sensibles et complexes et il y
a une telle perte de mémoire qu'elles
font fuir le personnel politique et donc
personne ne veut aller au ministère de
l'autre mère. Il y en a un qui a besoin
d'une résurrection politique qui se dit
au moins je m'y colle.
Il a soulagement général à Paris ou
c'est pas moi tous et génie c'est que
les autres il est quand même extra. Oh
il y va il y va super c'est héroïque. Et
en fait c'est pas c'est pas son geste
c'est ce que ça dit des autres qui
veulent pas y aller de un. Moi j'avais
reçu des messages d'amis de l'étranger
qui nous ont dit "Mes pauvres amis vous
êtes tellement mal considérés qu'on vous
file l'espagnol.
C'est atroce.
qui devait jamais revenir en France,
c'est
celui qui c'est vous imaginez la
violence de ce que de ce que bien sûr
mais pour un politique
le pire c'est de quitter son pays pour
aller faire la politique dans un autre
pays ça pour quand même c'est changer de
crèmerie politique c'est pas un crime
capital en politique quitter son pays ça
devient autre chose. Et donc lui il se
dit "Je prends le sujet le plus
pouilleux, c'est pas grave comme
personne ne le veut, il va faire les
outres mè." Et en fait la classe
politique comme la classe médiatique a
un immense soulagement. Il se dit "Ah
quelqu'un et cetera il y a les caméras
sur Mayotte, on l'a toutes les 3
semaines sur notre île même quand il y a
rien à faire."
Les caméras se tournent vers la
Nouvelle-Calédonie, il va sur la
Nouvelle-Calédonie et on l'a plus revu.
Au point que quand il y avait le voyage
du président de la République en avril
2025, il ne voulait pas l'accompagner
parce que les caméras seront pas sur
lui.
Oui, puis comme il a rien fait, c'est un
peu gênant, vous voyez.
Mais ça a dit beaucoup.
Il a peut-être fait des choses
extraordinairement. Oui oui oui oui
parce que parce qu'en fait c'est la
c'est c'est quand même ce qu'il est en
train de faire actuellement et
extraordinaire. C'est une première, je
pense, dans l'histoire de la République,
un ministre qui fait campagne contre sa
successeur avec une misogénie délirante
et qui se permet de de se dire
indispensable
qui a nourri dans la partie gauche de
l'hémicycle où il y a la plupart des
ultramarins tous les discours sur
l'autonomie et l'indépendance
à dessin
Alors que aux Antilles, il y a quand
même une violence délirante qui est
extrêmement grave, une criminalité euh
de drogue, de craque de qui qui a qui
fait une vague de mortalité incroyable.
La Guyane aussi a des non problèmes de
sécurité. La Guadeloupe, il y a pas
d'eau. Et lui, il les a hypnotisé avec
un discours sur est-ce qu'on peut ouvrir
les chantiers constitutionnels ?
Pourquoi pas les chantiers statutaires ?
Allons-y. Let's go. Je voudrais que les
uns et les autres comprennent bien. Une
discussion constitutionnelle ou
statutaire ne coûte pas un sous.
C'est beaucoup moins cher que d'aller
mettre de l'eau ou d'aller lutter contre
les narcoses.
Bon
et ça c'est l'habileté, vous voyez,
c'est le génie. C'est vraiment c'est
pour moi le le
ça ça a été visible par exemple dans le
toiletage institutionnel qu'ils ont
proposé à Mayotte dans la loi Mayotte de
programmation. Ils ont
le le conseil départemental de Mayotte
région Mayotte n'a pas de de dotation
pluriéannuelle. Chaque année, on se fait
euh balader par on a une dotation qui
est minime et réduite. Et donc là, cette
discussion statutaire, elle était euh
évidente pendant la renégociation sur le
sur le l'évolution institutionnelle du
de Mayotte. Qu'est-ce qu'a fait Paris ?
Ils ont proposé à mes élus de doubler le
nombre d'élus. Ah bah oui oui oui.
Discussion sur l'argent. C'est pas
nécessaire.
J'ai jamais vu ça. C'est c'est c'est un
niveau de
ça rappelle les années de de d'échange
des êtres humains contre la véroterie
quoi. C'est c'est terrible. C'est c'est
terrible de de
d'incompéten de mépris, de
voilà d'inconséquence en fait pour les
Est-ce que vous avez essayé d'alerter
directement l'opinion publique en disant
voilà nos territoires ultramarins sont
richissimes
nous permettent d'avoir une influence
pour être encore valable sur les chiqu
international le pouvoir central ne
comprend pas français réveill Z-vous, on
est en train de se faire déposséder de
notre culture, de nos territoires, de
Non, je le fais avec vous, mais je le
fais avec vous, mais je pense que le
désarroi au niveau hexagonal est tel que
fait on n'est pas très réceptif,
ici et moi je suis pas
euh
je je mal à condamner. Je comprends très
bien que je comprends très bien que pour
l'hexagone, l'angoisse soit forte.
les gens ont du mal à boucler les fins
de mois. Le désordre à Paris est tel que
ça désoriente tout le monde. C'est
extrêmement que la catatonie émotionnel,
la catatonie intellectuelle,
boucler les fins de mois, si on une une
industrie qui peut avoir du gaz pas
cher, ce sera plus facile pour boucler
les fins de mois. Pourquoi pourquoi
onaborde pas ça le sujet de cette
manière-là ? Si si on est capable avec
l'augmentation du prix de l'or, la
montagne d'or en Guyane, si on fait ça
relativement proprement,
ça permet de remettre un peu de sous
dans de mettre du beurre dans les
épinards. Ça permettre ça va permettre
de redévelopper proprement les choses,
de de rester à flot. Là la France elle
coule et les territoriux du train marin.
Moi ce que je dis à la communauté,
gardez toujours un œil sur les économies
insulaires, c'est le canarie dans la
mine. Si eux cannent, la France canne.
Mais en fait c'est c'est compliqué parce
que il y a un passif historique qui
n'est pas digéré.
Il y a et comme il y a un tabou énorme,
il y a une incapacité à à avoir une
discussion qui est saine. Donc au lieu
d'avoir une discussion stratégique
et nous en fait Mayotte c'est un c'est
que des histoires singulières mais
Mayotte a choisi de rester française.
Donc en fait et c'est pour ça que je dis
c'est malgré Paris parce que nous on a
pas arrêté de nous poser la question, il
y a d'autres territoires qui ne veulent
plus rester et avec qui Paris
maintient une relation qui n'est pas
saine. Vous voyez pour moi la
difficulté, on parlait du qu d' dorsé la
difficulté du qu dorsé c'est de ne pas
comprendre qu'on est devenu une
puissance moyenne et donc d'agir comme
telle. Pour moi, être une puissance
moyenne n'est pas grave.
Puissance de moyenne impuissance,
c'est pas une question.
Tout n'est pas sexuel mon cher.
Néanmoins,
néanmoins. Néanmoins, le sujet c'est que
ça
hashtag hashtag faire des choix,
c'est pas grave. La taille n'est pas
tout.
Le sujet c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait
avec.
Et donc et donc comme on refuse de se
remettre en question au qui doré, ben on
s'éparpille et donc on ne fait rien.
C'est ça le problème. Le sujet c'est de
de se dire "Je veux aller faire ma
tournée dans les grands lacs, je veux
aller à Tatawin Liso et puis j'ai un
problème à Cayenne où j'en ai un autre à
Point à pitre, c'est secondaire." Et en
fait c'est ça qui ne va pas. C'est de la
même manière, on se dit sur la question
européenne, je veux absolument aller
aider le village roumain, mais j'ai mon
village en Corè qui fonctionne pas. Si
vous voulez, au bout d'un moment,
les les les nationaux, les Françaises,
les Français, on se regarde et on se dit
"Mais on s'est fait eu". Enfin, il y a
un truc qui Marine Le Pen a été
accueilli grand bras ouvert par Marine
Le Pen a été accueilli à bras ouvert
Mayotte.
Non. Alors, Marine Le Pen à Mayotte,
enfin le le RN à Mayotte, c'est euh
beaucoup plus fin que ça. Marine Le Pen,
quand elle est en campagne
présidentielle à Mayotte, elle reste 4
jours
campagne présidentielle. Tous les autres
candidats n'y ont pas mis le pied,
aucun. Il survolle pour aller à la
Réunion, sur passe au-udessus de
Mayotte. Il ne s'arrête pas mais elle
reste 4 jours.
L'ERN a fait de de Mayotte un totem
parce que c'est une île qui souhaite
rester française et qui est musulmane
et qui accueille Marine Le Pen
triomphalement parce que c'est le seul
parti qui parle du sujet principal qui
préoccupe les maoris, c'est
l'immigration.
Le deuxième partie qui fait de très
fortes corps sans que Mélanchon mette
les pieds, c'est LFI parce que LFI a
parlé d'eau pendant très longtemps qui
était notre deuxième sujet de
préoccupation très important. Le jour où
les parties se remettront à considérer
les électeurs ultramarins comme des
électeurs comme les autres et pas des
indigène, ils leur parleront à comme
tous les électeurs de leurs problèmes
avec des solutions, pas juste un
diagnostic avec des solutions fondé
infondé farfelu ou je sais pas quoi.
C'est ça. C'est-à-dire que le RN comme
LFI, on développait des discours sur les
autres mères avec chaque territoire et
en fait les autres parties rien.
Et et donc vous pouvez pas vous attendre
à ce qu'ils aient une stratégie
pour nous dire ce qu'ils veulent faire
des territoires ultramarins. Ils sont
même pas capables de parler à leurs
électeurs.
Donc ils ne connaissent pas les sujets.
Moi, je ne partage pas les diagnostics
de de de ces deux parties. Néanmoins, je
constate queen fait, ils ont un des
échos énormes localement qu'il
travaillent ce terrain avec le RN. On
avait à Mayotte, une visite
d'un cadre mais vraiment top niveau du
RN au moins tous les 4 mois.
Un labourage de terrain à l'ancienne
hallucinant.
Hallucinant et la fille qui est très peu
représentée en fait et et le RN n'est
pas structuré. comme parti à Mayotte,
ils sont très peu nombreux. Donc c'est
vraiment c'est euh le parti à Paris qui
a décidé d'investir et symboliquement
c'est très important pour eux. Et
comment dire LFI ? C'est l'importance
des réseaux sociaux. Ils sont quasiment
inexistants en terme de partie mais en
fait ils ont fait des tonnes de vidéos
de TikTok de sur le sujet de l'eau et
les prises de parole et et c'est viral à
Mayotte parce que ils l'onté pendant
très longtemps et quand ils l'ont
abandonné il reculent.
Moi, je les combats sur les questions de
l'immigration et quand leur position a
était connue, il recul aussi. Mais
moi, j'ai toujours dit aux autres
parties, mais travaillez sur ma
travaillez
juste venez faire campagne. Monsieur
Gluxmanne ou euh madame qui va faire
campagne pour les européennes à la
Réunion et qui peut pas prendre 2h à
Mayotte, venez pas me fatiguer avec vos
scores.
J'ai jamais vu un électeur à qui on sert
pas la main qui va voter pour vous. Ça
n'existe pas. ni à maotte ni ailleurs.
Donc vous faites votre taf, on
rediscute.
C'est ça le la difficulté. Donc en fait
quand quand on parle de l'abandon,
effectivement il y a il y a des parties
qui investissent les outresem, il y en a
deux.
Et donc qui prospère sur le le
l'indigence dans laquelle se trouvent
les territoires, l'absence de réponse de
l'État, la l'incohérence de ce qui est
développé. Donc ça ça
c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
douloureux parce que ça participe de
l'inconfort en métropole parce qu'ils
lisent ils lisent les résultats
électoraux, ils se disent "Mais
le FN a fait le le Rassemblement
national a fait la dernière fois
à Mayot ?" Je crois qu'ils ont fait 65
70 je sais plus. C'est énorme.
C'est énorme.
Revenons, revenons sur mon côté un peu
pragmatique, chiqué, international,
exploitation des ressources, tout ça.
On est on est resté sur notre caillou,
vous avez fini de nous expulser.
Non, pas tout de suite. C'est ça
la France, un investissement de 4
milliards avec un énorme gisement de gaz
d' côté avec le Mozambique pour pouvoir
continuer d'avoir une petite station
d'écoute ou tout ça. 4 milliards, c'est
pour c'est rien pour
c'est une poussière. C'est
c'est incompréhensible. C'est c'est
c'est plus qu'une volonté. C'est de la
forfaiture
en terme économique, en terme humain
parce que les maor les maor c'est comme
les overriens. Oui.
Les maoris c'est c'est
mais mais en fait je pense que là où
c'est pour ça que ça interroge beaucoup
plus que le territoire. C'est-à-dire que
là où il y a il y a Mayotte et
territoire insulair parce que si vous
êtes aller en Corse aussi parce que j'ai
des collègues Corse, on y allé et
cetera.
La difficulté pour l'État aujourd'hui
avec un grand E, c'est euh comment
est-ce que vous fonctionnez alors que
vos propres capacités sont réduites.
C'est-à-dire que une entreprise, les
grandes multinationales ont plus de
pouvoir qu'un état, plus d'argent, plus
de moyens, plus de personnel que ce qui
est le fondement de l'État, c'est-à-dire
la défense, la monnaie,
l'impôt et la frontière, ben vous les
avez perdu.
Donc en fait l'État ne sait plus exister
que par son administration qui tourne à
vide
parce que l'administration c'est son
rôle fondamental c'est d'administrer ce
que vous voyez à Mayotte et ce que vous
voyez dans d'autres territoires même
hexagonal hexagonaux c'est l'absence
d'administration en fait
et donc vous avez une administration
plétorique qui n'a plus d'objectif
qui si ce n'est de produire de la norme
et dont on se rend compte
quotidiennement de la vacuité que c'est
inac in applicable. Bapsus, c'est
inapplicable
mais en plus ça ne produit rien si ce
n'est d'entretenir la nécessité d'une
administration pour gérer ce qu'elle a
créé. Mais elle arrive plus à créer du
concret. L'administration quand elle va
être face au désastre humain, le
désastre humain va forcément aller lui
poser des questions.
Elle peut pas s'interroger,
elle peut pas s'interroger
l'administration parce qu'elle est elle
est sans visage.
Donc en fait l'administration
aujourd'hui elle est arrivée mais pas du
tout que dans les territoires
ultramarins, est arrivée à un niveau où
elle voit passer le personnel politique
en se disant de toute façon ils sont là
que pour très peu de temps. Je suis le
pouvoir et on est arrivé à une
administration qui est omnipotente qui
dit les éléments de langage à son
ministre et c'est ce qui fait que vous
avez une ligne donc pour Mayotte c'est
française par erreur ne pas investir
mais c'est sur d'autres sujets une
imbécilité crasse qui se remet jamais en
question sur l'Afrique ou sur voilà ça
continue on est dans le mur mais on
creuse et on trouve toujours pas de
pétrole, c'est pas grave. Euh mais en
fait ce que ce que ce que je dis est
important puisque pas par flatterie mais
l'administration n'écoute plus le
pouvoir politique. Le pouvoir politique
c'est l'élection. Donc vous avez une
administration qui agit en dehors de
tout mandat et de tout contrôle.
C'est grave ce que vous dites là.
C'est extrêmement grave mais c'est un
constat.
Et le problème du précédent qu'a créé
Musk avec Trump du Dodge, c'est que ça a
fait naître et prospérer l'idée chez
beaucoup d'élus partout dans le monde
que oui, on peut agir contre une
administration qui ne travaille pas ou
qui n'applique plus les décisions du
politique.
Et c'est un vrai débat philosophique
très important. C'est pas c'est pas la
fantaisie d'un milliardaire et d'un et
d'un dictateur aux États-Unis
parce que ça fait réfléchir beaucoup
d'élus en Europe et moi je n'ai aucun
doute sur le fait que ce sera dans le
débat de la présidentielle qu'elle soit
l'année prochaine ou en 2027
parce que fondamentalement
vous avez aujourd'hui une haute
administration
qui fonctionne en vas closent
le politique qui a un mandat
et qui, puisqu'on parle de politique
fiction, si elle était face à un pouvoir
qu'elle considère fasciste,
et ben elle va résister
contre ce mandat qui aura été élu.
Si Marine Marine Le Pen est élue, elle
aura une une marge de manœuvre
équivalent à une feuille de cigarette.
C'est ça.
Mais si vous êtes déjà avec un pouvoir
où juste actuellement la haute
administration considère juste que les
macronistes sont ineptes et elle refuse
d'appliquer les consignes, vous imaginez
bien que il y en a deux trois qui vont
considérer qu'ils sont les gens moulins
de je sais pas quelle époque et qui vont
décider qu'ils n'appliqueront pas les
consignes. Le sujet c'est pas moi je
suis ni de près ni de loin. Le sujet il
est philosophique, il est démocratique.
Est-ce que c'est normal que la haute
administration décide seule en dehors de
tout contrôle démocratique, de tout
mandat de ce qui est bien ou mal ?
Je veux dire c'est un vrai problème.
C'est un vrai problème. Donc par exemple
sur la question de est-ce que Mayotte
est française la ligne au qu d'ors
non la ligne au qu d'ors c'est Mayotte
française est une erreur historique.
C'est l'ambassadeur Gérard Aaro qui
était à Washington qui l'affirme, qui le
tweet. C'est beaucoup d'autres qui le
disent euh des des diplomates français
qui n'ont aucun complexe à le dire. Euh
enfin vraiment ils ont aucun problème.
C'est la ligne euh au sein de des
armées, c'est de dire "Oui, c'est un
territoire national et il faut le garder
et c'est pour d'autres ministères, bah
c'est trop cher." Par exemple pour la
caisse de sécurité sociale au niveau
national pour le ministère de la santé,
c'est de dire faut surtout pas que les
Maoré aient accès à leur plein droit
puisque les droits sociaux sont aussi
ouverts aux étrangers en situation
régulières compte tenu des
régularisations massives à Mayotte, ça
nous coûterait beaucoup trop cher.
Moralité, vous privez des ressortissants
français de leur droit parce qu'on a
laissé transformer cette île en passoir.
Est-ce que les ressortissants français
de Mayotte, c'est les Français peuvent
attaquer l'administration en justice ?
On pourrait. Le sujet c'est que euh
je pense que la comme on a la liberté de
circulation pour accéder à nos droits en
fait, on quitte l'île.
Et puis Mayotte, c'est un désert
judiciaire.
Il y a très peu d'avocats
et donc
ça demande une culture
une culture du combat juridique qui est
absente de l'île. Là par exemple, vous
savez, il y a des collectifs qui sont
constitués pour attaquer l'État sur la
question de l'eau et en fait ça râ
énormément et il y a très peu de
plaignant alors que la crise elle est
manifeste, elle est profonde et en fait
les gens ne passent pas le cap
d'aller sur des plaintes et cetera, de
faire de la paperasse. Je sais pas si
c'est qu'une question d'argent. Je pense
qu'il y a aussi un rapport à la justice
où on se dit de toute façon elle est
contre nous parce que à Mayotte la
justice elle est rendue euh de manière à
ce que elle soit favorable à la victime.
Dans l'esprit de beaucoup de juges, la
victime c'est le migrant. Donc le Mauré
même en légitime défense, il lui il se
fait condamner. Donc en très peu de
temps, la justice c'est complètement
elle est elle est perçu à Mayotte comme
contre les Maoré. Donc on on on n'y a
pas recours. Elle est chère. Elle est
chère. Les associations vont aider les
migrants. Il quand même c'est 70 ou 80 %
des dossiers euh au tribunal
administratif ou euh au au tribunal tout
court concerne des ressortissants
étrangers à Mayotte. C'est quand même
une proportion colossale
et euh c'est euh une judiciarisation qui
est euh pour les Français en leur
défaveur. Il y a quand même des
jugements qui sont euh
à peine à peine audible. Enfin,
quelqu'un qui s'est fait agresser sur la
route, il était en moto. Euh, il s'est
fait caillasser, s'est fait prendre sur
un barrage, il s'est fait agresser. Euh
président du tribunal dans la
condamnation lui a dit "Enfin, vous
savez bien que vous pouvez pas prendre
la route comme ça et vous balader
après-midi. Vous savez que c'est
dangereux ?"
Bah si, bien sûr que si.
Et admettons
donc si vous voulez après quand les
mêmes demandent leur évacuation parce
qu'ils sont fait agresser quelques
semaines après, la population a très peu
de compassion.
Quand vous avez beaucoup maintenant de
personnel de justice qui est domicilié à
la réunion et qui vient rendre justice à
Mayotte, ce qui est contraire aux
principes fondamentaux pour la justice
qui dit que les juges doivent vivre sur
le lieu sur lequel il rentre justice,
euh
ça ça crée pas un climat où les les
maores et les maores se disent "La
justice va nous rendre justice."
On va passer aux questions internet.
Euh,
il y a des questions internet.
Ouais, il y en a il y en a il y en a
quelques-unes. Avant de passer aux
questions internet, euh j'aimerais faire
un message personnel parce que je
connais Mayotte
et et j'ai été accueilli par les Maor
euh et les les migrants aussi parce
qu'on a été euh à la campagne. Euh la
campagne qui est l'équivalent de la
brousse ou de la jungle. On a fait
quelques volets volets volet pardon qui
est l'équivalent du barbecue local
en pleine pénurie d'essence parce que
les stations service étaient en grève et
qu'on avait plus d'essence et que on a
on a été quand même aidé par tout le
monde. Donc on a une dette, on va
essayer de la remplir, de la combler et
de l'honorer. Il faut aider Mayotte,
c'est notre pointe de diamant dans dans
le coin. C'est une perle richissime
inexploitée, inexplorée et pas
respectée. Il faut que les Français
comprennent que
sans ça, on va perdre une carte
maîtresse dans la région et et il faut
bien comprendre.
Euh question internet. Bonsoir madame.
Je la prends, je l'ai même pas lu. Donc
faudra Bonsoir madame Youssoufa. Au vu
du tableau dressé,
les ultramarins doivent-ils prendre
leurs indépendances ? et se débrouiller
par eux-mêmes.
Ben, je pense que par exemple pour
Mayotte euh ça c'est un débat que qui
est très nourri par les Comoriens et et
soufflé par les Russes beaucoup. Je
voudrais juste signaler que avec la
revendication des comors, le jour où le
drapeau français s'abaisse à Mayotte,
Mayotte est immédiatement comorienne et
reconnue par la communauté
internationale. C'est-à-dire que la
possibilité d'une indépendance de
Mayotte est inexistante.
Euh sur les autres territoires
ultramarins, en fait, chacun a sa
trajectoire historique particulière.
Donc dans le Pacifique, si on parle par
exemple
euh de la Polynésie, ils sont sur une
trajectoire très très autonomiste là
avec un gouvernement local
indépendantiste.
Euh vous voyez que le débat fait rage et
est très violent en Nouvelle-Calédonie.
Il y a eu euh des débats euh
institutionnel enfin longs en Guyane où
ils sont eux sur une stratégie et une
ligne d'autonomie
euh qui a été nourrie par euh président
Macron et Emmanuel Vals. Donc en fait
moi ce qui me
ce qui m'interroge dans votre question,
c'est de dire se débrouiller par
eux-mêmes.
Faut comprendre que le phénomène de des
outresem,
nous sommes à 10000 km à ce qu'on nous
impose par la réglementation de
consommer français.
Donc on ne peut pas consommer ce qui est
produit par nos voisins qui serait trois
fois moins cher, trois fois moins
polluant en terme de transport et
cetera.
Un peu comme dans les antidères,
on crée partout dans tous les
territoires ultramarins, on crée une
dépendance à la métropole. Ce terme
historique est très connoté parce que
c'est la mère patrie, nous les petits
enfants très méprisants
et et en fait on crée et on
institutionnalise la dépendance.
Donc la perception que les outresemères
sont un poids, c'est en fait méconnaître
euh l'apport stratégique et financier
par la vente par exemple de droits de
pêche dans la zone d'économie exclusive.
Par exemple, donc il y a un marché
européen où on vend des droits de pêche.
La France vend énormément de droits de
pêche. Dans les eaux de la Réunion de
Mayotte, il y a des pêcheurs portugais,
espagnols qui viennent acheter du thon
que vous allez consommer en boîte petit
navire. Bah c'est c'est d'autres
c'est c'est ou d'autres c'est c'est
pêché dans les eaux de l'océan Indien
qui sont très poissonneuses.
Voilà. Enfin ça fait partie de ce que la
France monille. Donc euh une lecture
purement comptable à ce jeu-là, je suis
pas sûr sans insulter personne euh que
l'Auvergne rapporte des masses. Vous
voyez, si on commence à faire le pays
par rapport au PIB de chaque
département,
euh
la cruge. Voilà, je je voulais pas
si tu veux je crois je l'avais déjà
mentionné donc mais
brasse voyez voilà mais en fait le sujet
c'est pas combien vous rapportez
le sujet c'est pas combien vous
rapportez c'est pas ça le pacte
républicain
sinon il faut juste nous dire on n pas
reçu le mé mot
parce que on n'est pas assez nombreux
pour se battre sur ce type de discussion
mais juste il faut que tout le monde
comprenne que ça sera la même règle pour
tout le monde. Et si vous décidez que
les quartiers nord de Marseille sont une
plie, bah ils sortent de la République.
La scène Saint- Nice, c'est la même
chose.
En fait, on y va quoi en fait ? Et puis
après on reste avec bah Neïi,
le Touquet
peut-être
qui rapporte que quelques mois dans
l'année
et après ça fera la même dislocation
avec l'Europe, non ?
Même motif, même punition.
Question internet que je découvre.
Bonsoir. Que pensez-vous des petites
entreprises type Osmoson ou autres
entreprises pour desser l'eau de mer
après les tempêtes pour interrogation,
pas besoin de groupe électrogène. Ça
marche chez les petits marêchés pauvres
africains. Une idée en passant. Merci
pour votre clarté.
Je vous en prie. Le sujet de des
solutions de secours, c'est que ce sont
des solutions de secours et que nous on
a besoin de solutions systémiques. On a
largement dépasser le stade à Mayotte
euh de
Je l'ai expliqué tout à l'heure, moi
j'ai pour ambition qu'on sorte de la
survie.
C'est-à-dire que effectivement, on a
besoin de solutions qui soient
intelligentes, qui soient autonomes et
je connais pas cette entreprise mais il
y a il y a plein de solutions malines.
Le sujet c'est pourquoi est-ce qu'on
aurait droit à moins que d'autres ?
C'est ce que ce que je comprends pas,
c'est pourquoi on va nous dire euh
ce sera le moins 10 ans et ce sera du de
l'expérimental
sur un territoire français. C'est c'est
je méprise pas les innovations. Je dis
simplement à Mayotte, on n'est pas des
rats de laboratoire,
on est des Français et on vous demande
pas d'inventer l'eau chaude, on vous
demande d'avoir de l'eau. Donc on va pas
aller demander des solutions folles. On
demande des routes, un hôpital, un
aéroport et des bâtiments avec des
briques et un toit. pas des containers
climatisés, pas un aéroport avec des des
containers empilés pour faire la tour de
contrôle.
Si c'est ça la reconstruction de
l'aéroport de Mayotte, c'est des
container qui sont empilés. Ça c'est
notre nouvelle tour de contrôle
inauguré. Inauguré, faut assumer de
faire une inauguration sur un truc
pareil.
Notre hôpital est toujours avec des
bâches.
Je veux dire, on je demande pas
je demande pas un petit bidon pour aller
faire de l'eau en urgence. Je demande
une usine de dessement qui soit
écologique, qui ne rejette pas de l'eau,
de la saumure dans mon lagon qui est
fermé, qui a un trésor écologique. Je
demande à ce qu'on fasse qu'on équipe
par exemple toutes les maisons
individuelles de cuve pour récupérer
l'eau de pluie. Je demande à ce que on
cesse d'utiliser de l'eau qui a été qui
est parmi la plus chère de France qui a
été traitée pour aller euh
faire la lessive. Par exemple,
l'utilisation intelligente de l'eau où
vous prenez pas de l'eau potable pour
faire tout et n'importe quoi. À Mayotte,
sur une île de 355 km²r dans ce génie de
pays des Lumières avec des Nobelles et
des je sais pas quoi, on a toujours pas
été foutu de me créer un système qui
fait qu'on ne gaspille pas de l'eau qui
est potable pour n'importe quel usage,
un usage pour aller faire des chantiers
ou que sais-je encore. C'est c'est ce
niveau d'ynapsie. Donc si vous voulez le
projet pour un village africain, très
bien, tant mieux. Mais en fait, c'est
pas à cette échelle que je réfléchis.
Peut-être que je vi montrer la tour de
contrôle. C'est une blague. Ouais, c'est
ouf hein.
C'est une blague.
Non, non, c'est pas
allez voir, allez voir. Tour de contrôle
Mayotte. Aéroport de Mayotte.
C'est pas une blague malheureusement.
Non mais vous avez des beaux escaliers
en fer.
C'est
c'est l'indigence.
C'est blanc. C'est blanc. C'est pour
éviter de trop climatiser. C'est ça.
C'est l'indigence.
C'est c'est Ouais. C'est c'est chaud
quand même.
Une autre question.
Euh oui, concernant les gilissements de
gaz total par exemple boîte encore
française pour l'instant. Euh ils vous
ont proposé d'explorer le gaz. Ils ont
ils vous ils vous
Ah mais non non non. J'ai parlé tout à
l'heure du fait que Paris a interdit
l'exploration d'hydrocarbure et
l'exploitation d'hydrocarbure dans ses
outreemers. Ah mais oui,
vaut mieux en voyer total aller se faire
accuser de participer à des crimes et de
je sais pas quoi que de les faire opérer
chez nous.
Et quel est le nom de la personne qui a
proposé ça de pas exploiter nos
ressources ?
Sauf, je crois que c'est Madame Royale.
Madame Royale ? Laquelle ? Là c'est
Golen.
Ah celle qui était avec les pingouins.
La même.
Et concernant les militaires, les
militaires et total ils peuvent faudrait
vérifier. Je pense que les Tinker
viewers sont sont seront meilleurs que
moi.
Et concernant les militaires, il vous
aident un peu pour le lobbying du genre
sauver Mayotte, c'est vachement
important pour nous. Ça nous permet
d'avoir quand même un doigt, un pied
dans la région que c'est la région qui
bouge beaucoup et que c'est quand même
je sais
pas de quel organe vous parlez.
Néanmoins, on peut avoir quelques sujets
avec les militaires parce que quand ils
sont en train de faire la même connerie
que qu'au Mali, c'est-à-dire d'entraîner
les les Comoriens comme si c'était des
partenaires, voyez, moi je j'ai du mal à
dialoguer, les
c'est compliqué.
Ah ben, on a des accords de coopération
avec les comars. Vous savez, le pays qui
nous revendique, on est en partenariat.
Si vous envoyez les Alsiens pour aller
travailler avec les Allemands en en
Non, on peut pas se permettre cette
parallèle là
en 1909. Mais si c'est ça
si c'est ça
c'est ça c'est ils sont en train de vous
vous attaquer. On vous dit vous voudriez
pas faire un peu de collaboration
sans mauvais jeu de mot ?
Moi je le vis très mal en fait. Je le
vis très mal là, je le dis calmement
mais ça se passe très mal avec le
ministère de la défense et et
l'étatmajor parce que si vous voulez le
discours du qu d' dorsé en fait de dire
les comor sont un partenaire même s'il
revendiquent c'est du vent faut les
laisser c'est pas grave et de
minorer
la menace ne refuser de qualifier ça
d'ingérence alors que c'est vraiment une
ingérence caractérisée la loi sur les
ingérences qui est passée à l'Assemblée
ne mentionne pas les comor Ouais,
c'est top. Enfin, je veux dire les mecs,
c'est c'est après être venu à Mayotte,
hein, le rapporteur, c'est monsieur
Houlier, il est venu à Mayotte, il a
constaté et alors remonter Hop là et
non, on parle pas des comors, c'est pas
le sujet. On va parler des Russes, on va
parler d'Azerbaïdjan mais comor non pas
du tout. C'est Mayot, le seul territoire
français habité revendiqué par une
puissance étrangère. C'est le seul. Donc
je veux dire
c'est c'est c'est simple, bête et
méchant, mais non. Et en fait nous on
pousse le vis jusqu'à se dire est-ce que
quand même on pourrait pas les financer,
les former, les équiper
et ça c'est quand même du génie. les
mêmes qui appellent à envahir Mayotte
qui ont protesté officiellement pour
dire que l'opération Wambouchou était
une opération d'ingérance sur les terres
comoriennes
qui ont appelé à envoyer des des quassa
quissa, des bateaux en masse pour
prendre le contrôle de Mayotte.
Et après moi j'ai des photos avec nos
uniformes en train de serrer la louche
et de dire on va les former les gardes
côte comorien équipé de bateaux français
alors que notre flotte est insuffisante
et a été en partie détruite par Shido,
toujours pas reconstruite
et et nos militaires on pose fièrement
avec ceux qui qui encouragent et qui
pilotent le trafic humain.
Quand je dis qu'on apprend pas, qu'on a
pas l'humilité de s'interroger, que
c'est un scénario à la malienne,
la l'armée française a travaillé avec
les PCes avant qu'il fassent le PCH.
C'est nous qui les avons formés.
Question internet. Bonsoir. Merci pour
votre pragmatisme.
Seriez-vous prête à devenir ministre des
outremères ?
Et auriez-vous des suggestions adéquates
pour tous ces territoires ? Non.
Euh
parce que je pense que je veranfaron.
Mais fanfaron, j'aime beaucoup ce que
vous le dites. Néanmoins, euh je je suis
flatée, touchée. Je suis pas sûre que ce
soit un cadeau que vous me proposiez. Je
pense que comment dire ce campur
naimamchu
euh résume la difficulté de la mission.
Euh mais plus sérieusement, je pense que
chevinement avait raison. Soit un
ministre est d'accord, soit il ferme sa
gueule et il se casse. C'est-à-dire que
moi je suis trop indisciplinée, j'ai
aucun parti euh et je ne pense pas que
ma contribution pourrait être comment
dire pertinente, mais surtout je je
d'abord je suis pas élue par ambition
politique. C'est-à-dire que moi j'avais
une carrière, une vie avant, j'ai été
journaliste et puis consultante. Je suis
élue par désespoir. C'est la situation
est tellement grave à Mayotte, on est
tellement peu nombreux. Je me suis
engagé par révolte. Donc quand même
suffisamment de cerveau ici à Paris pour
que quelqu'un aille se continuer les
ordres de la République. Et ouais, vous
voyez, je suis pas vraiment pas
indispensable. Je suis pas sûre d'être
un cadeau dans un ministère mais je
pense que c'est connu à Paris sinon on
m'aurait proposé quelque chose.
Alors deux questions, les deux dernières
qui viennent d'arriver.
Oui.
Alors une question de Protego Maxima.
Quelle preuve concrète concernant
l'ingérence russe ? Pour interrogation.
Bah l'ingérange russe, elle est
totalement assumée. Vous avez différents
tweets de Lavrov qui parle de Mayotte et
qui fait le parallèle avec de de tweets
et puis de déclarations publiques, des
conférences de presse et cetera.
Euh les visites du de l'ambassadeur
russe à Moroni et ces déclarations sont
qui appellent à soutenir les comorts
pour prendre le contrôle de Mayotte par
tous les moyens sont euh publs et filmés
et revendiqués. Et euh comment dire ? On
le voit en fait si vous allez sur
TikTok, si vous allez sur Facebook, vous
voyez en quelques années apparaître sur
les les réseaux sociaux à Mayotte. C'est
les deux principaux he TikTok et et
Facebook, des drapeaux russes et puis
des faux profils. Et en fait, on
reconnaît les faux profils, enfin moi je
je sais les reconnaître parce que c'est
des profils où il y a à peu près très
peu de publications, très peu d'amis
très récents
et qui tiennent un discours. Et souvent
c'est écrit soit dans un mauvais
français où on comprend que c'est un
hallophone mais ce n'est pas un
hallophone de la région. C'est-à-dire
que nous, on sait discerner qui parle.
Euh et des fois quand ils parlent où ils
essayent en chimoré, ils vont pas
utiliser notre dialecte, ils vont
utiliser euh des dialectes par exemple
c'est du chat GPT où ils ont pris du
swili, du continent et des choses comme
ça. Et donc on voit
le dernier le dernier indice que c'est
vraiment de l'ingérance et que c'est
politique, c'est que pour moi c'est
vague de de d'attaque, je vais vous
parler juste de ma page il y en a
beaucoup mais sur ma page c'est euh
chaque fois que je fais des déclarations
sur les comor
ou sur les Russes, mais j'ai une vague
et c'est très violent Et puis c'est
nourri, c'est des centaines et des
centaines de messages et puis après ça
redescend. Donc c'est vraiment
totalement lié à l'activité politique
ou à mes déclarations qui sont très
claires par rapport à ce que je pensais
écor
et comment dire
le
l'ingérence
l'ingérence russe est assumée
c'est-à-dire qu'elle n'est pas du tout
cachée. Président Poutine parle de
Mayotte, son ministre des affaires
étrangères, son ambassadeur
GG GG Gérard Raro
qui va dire que bon Mayotte
Oui, c'est une erreur historique et que
ça encore. Vous vous sentez pas un peu
en en tenaille ?
Comment ça ?
Entre Aro qui dit que c'est une erreur
historique, Poutine qui veut vous
déstabiliser.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec tout ça ?
On se bat.
On alerte, on se défend.
Nous, notre seul secours, c'est
l'opinion.
C'est que les gens en fait pour tuer
Mayotte, il y a pas besoin de beaucoup
d'activités. Il y a juste besoin de ne
rien faire. C'est ce que fait l'État.
C'est le pourrissement.
C'est pas c'est pas des gens qui
s'agitent, hein. C'est des gens qui
laissent la situation se décomposer, se
déliter pour écurer la population et
qu'on parte. Nous, on est français. On
va s'installer ailleurs pour que nos
enfants juste en sécurité pour vivre
normalement parce que psychologiquement
on n'y arrive pas, physiquement on peut
plus soigner. Donc on part
temporairement mais on part mais voilà
et c'est ça l'objet
c'est que vous êtes chez vous c'est
votre terre vous faites caillasser, vous
faites incendier, vous faites
caillasser, vous faites incendier, vous
faites caillasser, vous faites
incendier. Au bout de 6 mois, 5 ans, 10
ans, vous arrivez plus. Est-ce qu'il y a
des phénomènes de
milice paramilitaire qui se montent en
dehors de tout
il a des tentatives et c'est là où
l'État agit en disant surtout pas.
Et moi, ça a été l'argument pour dire
bah vous faites w bouchou parce que
sinon c'est les gens qui vont prendre
eux-mêmes les armes puis vous me
trouverez pas pour les les dénoncer
parce que vous n'avez rien fait. Et ça
je le dis publiquement pour que les
choses soient bien claires. Parce que le
monopole de la violence c'est l'État.
Mais s'il ne défend pas la population,
c'est de la légitime défense.
Et donc à laisser les Maoré face à leur
bourreau, à obliger cette coexistence
qui est un viol permanent de nos droits,
de notre terre, de notre identité,
c'est non assistant sa population en
danger et c'est de la légitime défense.
Donc quand on appelle à l'aide et qu'on
demande l'intervention de la police, de
la gendarmerie, de de de l'armée, c'est
pour que ça reste quelque chose de
légal, de simple, de clair et du droit.
C'est parce qu'on est en République
queon a besoin du glève et du bouclier
de la République.
et les bisounours qu'il viennent faire
un tour une semaine à Mayotte, les mêmes
qui arrivent et qui nous donnent des
leçons du d'humanisme et cetera, de
droits des uns et des autres quand ils
se sont fait caillasser, quand ils ont
eu leurs enfants qui sont allés chercher
en en avec des lacrimeaux qui sont les
premiers à demander leur évacuation,
il nous laisse nous
face à nos bourreaux.
Donc quand
les uns et les autres disent "On va se
se former en milice", j'alerte et je dis
"Je vous invite à vraiment vous bouger
parce que après on ne pourra plus dire
"On savait pas,
ce sera guerre civile." Et moi et moi je
je ne je
on m'a beaucoup tapé dessus en disant
"Tu alarmes et tu tu détruis l'image de
Mayotte et les gens c'est pas bon pour
le commerce, c'est pas bon pour notre
image et cetera."
Nous on nous a quand même tenu un
discours pendant des années en disant
"Vous imaginez votre perception de
l'insécurité, vous exagérez."
Non non non, mais je veux dire c'est un
discours de manipulation mentale qui a
été mais extrêmement violent. On s'est
senti mal de notre propre souffrance.
On a été des victimes à qui on a dit
"Vous êtes des faibles et vous géniez.
Vous êtes des géniards.
Il a fallu que je fasse sortir les
vidéos que je montre et que je partage
avec mon élection. Voilà ce qui se passe
à Mayotte. Voilà juste
qu'on comprenne et que oui, quand vous
avez des gendarmes et des policiers qui
vont se battre face à des enfants qui
sont envoyés manipulés par des adultes,
c'est traumatisant. C'est aussi
traumatisant pour les forces de l'ordre
parce qu'il faut pas faut pas més ce que
c'est. C'est des scènes qui sont
semblables à celles que vous voyez à
Gaza quand vous voyez l'intifada.
Imaginez des hommes qui sont en
uniforme, qui sont face à des enfants
qui sont cagoulés, qui sont tout petits
mais qui balancent des choses qui sont
mortelles.
C'est nos forces de l'ordre. J'ai jamais
vu des choses pareilles.
Mais mais en fait c'estes ces enfants
sont avec des machettes dans un
supermarché.
Mais enfin,
et vous pouvez pas avoir des gens après
qui viennent nous dire les pauvres
petits quel pauvre petit ?
Mon pauvre petit a perdu son bras.
Mon pauvre petit pense que c'est normal
d'aller à l'école avec des lacrimeaux et
que son lycée soit cerné de barbelet
parce que tous les lycées, les collèges,
les écoles primaires à Mayotte sont
protégés par des barbelets.
Les forces de l'ordre sont toutes
mobilisées tous les jours pour aller
faire la rentrée et la sortie des écoles
pour éviter les affrontements tous les
jours. C'est le seul endroit de France
où les enfants entrent et sortent de
l'école sous protection et il y a quand
même des attaques.
C'est le seul endroit de France où les
assureurs refusent de payer l'assureur
des bus scolaires parce qu'ils se font
caillasser tout le temps.
Et là-dedans, le débat c'est le sexe des
anges de dire "Est-ce que les mineurs
sont des mineurs ? Est-ce que quand tu
as perdu ton ta main ou est-ce que quand
tu as perdu un œil ou la vie, c'est le
sujet c'était mineur
Il y a, je veux dire, il y a quelque
chose
de de hors sol dans les débats
qui fait qu'on est toujours 10 train
derrière et qu' en plus on se prend un
discours culpabilisant
qui qui fait que là, vous voyez, j'étais
dans les discussions avec je suis
toujours dans les discussions avec le
gouvernement sur la reconstruction. Les
bonhommes sont en train de me dire "Oui,
il y a des projets, vous savez, on peut
pas les financer parce que c'est des
coups partis."
Ah, je regarde, j'ai dit "Des coup
parti, je dis "C'est c'est encore un
discours sexuel ça ? C'est quoi votre
truc ?" J'ai dit "Non, c'est des projets
qui ont déjà été lancés."
Comment ?
Ah, dites-moi tout, ça m'intéresse.
Lesquels ? Non mais lesquels ?
Un coup parti trop vite.
Je dis "Lesquel ?"
Non mais parce que en fait dans votre
programme vous avez recyclé que des
projets qui n'avaient pas été faits et
là vous êtes en train de m'expliquer
dans le financement qu'ils auraient été
démarrés. Si Mayotte n'était pas un
désert judiciaire, un désert un désert
médical, on serait tous chez le médecin
parce que quand on vous écoute, tout a
déjà été fait et on voit rien. On voit
rien. On doute tous collectivement de
notre de notre capacité visuelle. Vous
m'expliquez qu'il y a des dossiers qui
qui peuvent pas qu'on peut pas budgetter
parce qu'en fait ils ont déjà été faits.
Ça ça vous rend voyez c'est c'est c'est
lunaire. C'est-à-dire que vous vous je
parle j'essaie de parler avec calme.
C'est une rage profonde profonde.
Je je mes interlocuteurs ont un niveau
de petits hommes en gris là.
Question internet.
Oui.
Madame la députée, comment pouvez-vous
défendre un développement séparé et une
identité strictement française
alors que culturellement,
limpistiquement,
humainement, un maor est bien plus
proche d'un habitant de muelli ou
d'enjuant que d'un savoyard et d'un
breton. Ah,
comment justifiez-vous ce paradoxe de
point ? demander une intégration totale
à un pays lointain tout en niant les
liens naturels, historiques et culturels
avec nos propres voisins.
Oh, c'est beau ça. C'est ça c'est la
merveille du discours Comorien. Je
rappelle que c'est la même chose que les
nazis avec l'enchelous, c'est la même
chose que les Russes avec les les
Ukrainiens. Vous voyez, c'est pourquoi
est-ce que la France c'est pas aussi la
Suisse-Romande ou la la Wallonie. Voyez,
c'est en fait, je comprends pas moi non
plus. C'est voyez, c'est la frontière,
c'est une création politique, c'est un
contrat. Ça n'a rien de naturel. Ça n'a
pas à voir avec la culture, ça n'a pas à
voir avec la langue, ça à voir avec les
choix d'un destin politique.
Donc les Comoriens ont décidé de prendre
leur indépendance.
Très bien. Formidable, good luck. Nous,
on a dit non merci. nos anciens ont dit
non merci et avec si je peux me
permettre une certaine lucidité parce
que c'est pas formidable avec Paris mais
contrairement au comit pas la troupe sur
la sur le visage. On n'est pas au top 10
de la corruption mondiale. On n'est pas
au top 10 du ridicule politique, on
n'est pas au top 10 des pches réguliers
ou de la pauvreté dans le monde. Vous
voyez les comor c'est pas Dubaï ni
Singapour. Faut pas non plus laisser
croire laisser croire non mais laisser
croire que on a on est passé à côté d'un
projet dingo d'une réussite incroyable
hein. Non non parce que quand on écoute
les LFI ou les uns et les autres qui
nous disent "Vous feriez mieux devenir
comorien". Je voudrais que les uns et
les autres comprennent ce à quoi ils
nous ils nous ils nous promettent.
Ils nous disent aller chez les voisins,
c'est tellement mieux.
Donc alors moi je voudrais juste
rappeler quand on fait un vote
quand les Comoriens et les quat îles ont
été consultés,
les maoré aussi, on a dépouillé.
Certains ont dit oui, certains ont dit
non. On fait son lit, on se couche.
Quand vous avez les enjoinés qui avaient
voté pour l'indépendance après qui
refont des manifes pour redevenir
français puis qui à nouveau reviennent
comme rien puis maintenant viennent ta
Mayotte. Nous, on peut pas gérer la
schizophrénie des voisins quand ils ne
savent pas où ils habitent, si ce n'est
qu'ils sont tous majoritairement à
Marseille pour être français et vivre de
de leur nationalité tout en revendiquant
Mayotte,
il y a un gros problème mais qui n'est
pas le nôtre.
Donc la proximité culturelle,
géographique et familiale a forceori
contre les autorités la créent en
laissant ouverte la frontière pour
qu'ensuite on nous dise "Oui, mais vous
êtes marié avec des comoriens, ils
travaillent chez vous, ils vivent chez
vous." Là, je voudrais juste qu'on aille
au bout de ce discours parce que ça fait
quand même un petit moment qu'on le
subit. à Mayot, il y a toujours un
discours pour nous expliquer. Soit vous
êtes des xénophobes qui haïsaient les
étrangers, vous ne voulez pas les
accueillir, vous les nourrissez pas,
vous êtes inhumain. Soit vous les
accueillez, vous les vous mariez et vous
vous vivez avec eux et vous les faites
travailler et vous les exploitez.
Dans les deux cas, Mayotte a toujours
tort. Mayotte a toujours tort. Et donc
les commandes
parce que la deuxième question de cette
personne c'est madame la députée, j'ai
travaillé 3 ans à l'hôpital de ma.
Voilà, c'est ça.
J'y ai vu des aides soignants Maoré
refuser de soigner des patients parce
qu'ils étaient comoriens. J'ai aussi vu
les maoré employés des ouvriers comien
gardien jardiners maçon puis ne pas les
payer. Comment pouvez-vous dénoncer les
coméiens sans dénoncer aussi les
comportements locaux qui participent à
la crise ? Mais oui,
on a on a c'est ça que c'est ça qui est
affreux. Mayotte sans les ma serait
tellement mieux hein.
C'est quand même incroyable. Non, non,
mais c'est-à-dire que 80 % de la
patientelle de l'hôpital de Mayotte
vient des comor le l'hôpital
fax s'est donné à Mayotte et appelle
pour qu'il y ait le le seul hélicoptère
qui a cherché les patients
comorien qui arrivent en Quoi ?
Les bonhommes, ils demandent leur visa.
Ils arrivent dans des situations
médicales désespérées. Les équipes
médicales françaises les soignent
à l'œil à l'œil avec vos impôts, nos
impôts, hein. Et les gens ils râent,
il râent.
C'est c'est quand même extraordinaire.
Nous nous assurés sociaux n'avons plus
de place à l'hôpital de Mayotte. On part
pour se soigner à nos frais, nous
assurés sociooré parce que il y a plus
de place dans l'hôpital parce que et
c'est normal un docteur ne tri pas ses
patients selon la nationalité. Les
patients comoriens arrivent dans des
situations beaucoup plus désespérées.
Donc on dit au patients maoré vous êtes
assuré, vous attendez.
Allez dans le privé qui n'existe pas.
Qui n'existe pas. Il y a quasiment pas
de médecine privée.
Question internet. Bonsoir. Pourquoi
l'ONU a condamné la France concernant ?
C'est ça qui est génial. C'est parce que
en fait chaque fois que je vais aller
m'exprimer publiquement sur les mailles
les comoriens qui déboulent en masse et
là ils vont ils sont en pétage de cap
total. Mais c'est normal et tant mieux
parce qu'à chaque fois il faut leur
rappeler deux trois trucs. Donc c'est
pas l'ONU qui condamne, c'est
l'assemblée générale de l'ONU et leur
décision n'a aucune valeur en terme de
droit par rapport aux frontières. Donc
pouvez avoir une condamnation, ce n'est
pas le conseil de sécurité. Ça c'est une
première chose importante. La deuxième
chose, c'est que si vous commencez à
remettre en cause le fait que Mayotte
est est restée française, vous remettez
en vote le référendum. Donc vous
remettez en vote votre propre
indépendance. Vous pouvez pas décider
que le vote à Mayotte ne valait pas un
clou, mais votre vote pour
l'indépendance était justifié et valide.
Il y a quand même quelque chose dans la
logique complètement falsificatrice au
niveau de l'histoire que propagent les
Comoriens qui est une propagande qui n'a
plus ni que ni tête. C'est-à-dire que
l'ONU n'a pas euh comment dire contredit
les les les frontières de la France.
C'est l'assemblée générale qui a
condamné. Il y a pas de processus de
décolonisation qui a été entamé parce
que il y a aucune demande de de Mayotte
de devenir comorienne. Il y a au
contraire un voisin qui est en train de
coloniser son voisin. Si un jour Paris
se réveiller, il sera en train d'aller à
l'ONU pour dire "J'en ai un là qui est
en train de nous envahir." Vous voyez,
c'est c'est c'est un peu faut faut
remettre l'église et la mosquée au
milieu du village.
Question internet. Oui.
Et si vous arrêtiez tous un tous de
payer vos impôts, de payer les impôts,
faire la greffe de l'impôt ou verser ça
par exemple la caisse des dépôts et
consignation.
Est-ce que vous payez vos impôts ? Oui,
mais moi je je alors d'abord je suis pas
pour la désobéissance civile sur ce
dossierlà en particulier parce que j'ai
pas du tout envie de donner la moindre
le moindre prétexte au gouvernement pour
nous saquer. On se fait déjà tellement
taper dessus, pas envie d'aller dans ce
genre de truc. Ça veut pas dire que ça
nous traverse pas l'esprit. Ça ve pas
dire qu'on n'y a pas déjà réfléchi, mais
on essaie d'être un peu plus moyen enfin
malin que que
l'indignation qui nous habite.
Question internet.
Bonsoir madame Youssoufa.
Bonsoir.
Il est évident que les médias ne
reflètent pas pleinement la réalité du
terrain. Pourquoi ne pas mettre
davantage en avant les problèmes de
Mayotte en utilisant les réseaux sociaux
et les médias citoyens ? Bah tu crois
qu'elle s'est déplacé ce soir ? Pourquoi
? Bon, passant. Pourquoi euh de pas
non, ça se fait beaucoup ça mais en fait
euh on parle beaucoup de Mayotte sur les
réseaux. Euh les maores et les maorées
sont très actifs aussi. Euh je pense
qu'on est dans une phase où euh
malgré ce que ce que je décris, moi je
suis très
optimiste dans le sens où Mayotte quand
j'ai dit qu'on avait plus rien à perdre,
on a muté génétiquement. On était des
gens très effacés, très timides, très
modestes et en fait maintenant
on a touché le fond de la piscine. On
peut plus que remonter. C'est ce qu'on
pense. Donc on va pas s'excuser
d'exister.
On n'est pas du tout à dire on veut plus
que d'autres mais on aura plus moins.
Donc on est combatif.
Question internet. Vous sentez-vous
personnellement en danger de par votre
position politique ? Et moi je j'abonde
ou je je je complète
la la DGSI, elle vous a proposé une
protection ? Est-ce que vous avez des
remontées de la DGSE vous disant bah vos
copains un peu hostiles, ils vous ont
mis un contrat sur la tête ou des choses
comme ça ? Non, j'ai déjà eu euh des
menaces de mort euh enfin souvent
régulièrement et euh comment dire j'ai
eu plusieurs fois des protections
qui ont fait que j'ai déménagé, je suis
protégée, j'ai été protégée plus ou
moins. Euh et c'est
dur à vivre parce que ça ça met en
danger les proches.
Je n'ai pas de permanence à Mayotte pour
ne pas mettre en danger le quartier et
le bâtiment et mon équipe.
Euh, j'ai la faiblesse de croire que la
population me protègerait.
Sinon, gloc 9 mm, c'est pas mal.
Non.
17 pour une femme ? Non.
Vous avez déjà fait du tir ?
Non.
Des parents militaires ? C'est une
blague ?
Non.
Même pas un petit coup de pompon dans un
centre de tir ?
Non. Oh !
Ça vous intéresserait de d'apprendre à
tirer ?
Non.
Pourquoi vous avez une aversion pour les
armes ?
Un
petit Glock 19. Non,
je vous sens gêné.
Euh,
je je l'ai dit tout à l'heure, c'est
l'État qui a le monopole de la violence.
Et donc pour moi, ce serait un échec
terrible qu'on en soit l'autodéfense. Je
ne le
je l'interdit pas du tout aux autres et
je comprends je condamne pas mais moi je
m'y refuse. Ça veut pas dire que on n
pas un tasur à la maison.
On n'est pas non plus des bisous nours.
Euh
mais euh mon engagement pour les
institutions, c'est c'est pas du flanc.
Donc il faut que je peux pas moi-même
par mes gestes ou mon comportement
dire que j'ai perdu confiance dans la
République. Donc non, je refuse de
m'armer. Euh et effectivement aussi par
un confort personnel où je suis pas très
à l'aise, j'ai même pas le permis de
conduire. Je suis pas sûr que serait pas
en train de me tirer une balle dans le
pied.
On arrive à la fin mal à droite.
On arrive à la fin de notre interview.
Est-ce que vous avez trois livres à
conseiller à notre communauté ?
Trois livres ?
Il y avait une autre question ? parce
que je vous vois
parce que je je deviens miope en ce
moment. Il y avait une porteuse donc
j'étais obligé
trois livres à conseiller
Saint-Germain ou la négociation qui un
tr boîte de nuit à Mayotte
aucune idée.
Saint-Germain ou la négociation qui est
un livre que m'a conseillé un ami
militaire et qui raconte
une négociation qui qui est qui a un
livre très fin sur la
psychologie pas en diplomatie mais en
négociation. Comment on retourne une
c'est un petit livre comme ça qui est
très sympa enfin qui est très fin.
Travaillez au GIGN votre ami ?
Non au raid au raid
euh comment ? Non non non. Et comment
dire ? Non et ben non parce que c'est
c'est un livre qui qui est classique
donc c'est pas c'est ça se passe je
crois protestant et catholique pour la
euh pour écart de religion. l'autre les
fleurs du mal de Baudler parce que
Baudler avait une passion pour les
Antilles et il a écrit des très très
belles lignes sur la beauté créole et
sur
les beautés ultramarines. Donc c'est
très beau. Un troisème livre euh je sais
pas moi, vous me posez Nicole.
Moi, j'aime beaucoup Pearl Buck qui
racontait la Chine, qui était une auteur
américaine qui a fille de missionnaire
et qui a beaucoup écrit sur la Chine et
c'était un de une de mes passions
d'enfants.
Avant,
c'est rien de ce à quoi vous attendiez.
Et nous on s'attend jamais à rien en
fait et on veut pas faire parler, on
veut pas transformer nos invités en
votilo donc on découvre à chaque fois.
C'est pour ça qu'on est en direct et et
euh et voilà, on n'est pas surpris. On
on aime explorer l'homme ou la femme en
face de nous pour comprendre les arcanes
de son raisonnement, l'architecture de
son raisonnement. Et
ah vous êtes bien ambitieuse. Vous
pensez qu'il y a un raisonnement, une
architecture,
c'est que du réactif, c'est ça ?
symptomatique.
On arrive à la fin et je veux je vous
pose la question, je vous laisse
réfléchir pendant que je vais je vais je
vais parler.
C'est pas une question, c'est un conseil
pour les jeunes générations, quelque
chose d'impérissable, une bouteille à la
mer. Et pendant que vous réfléchissez
une seconde, moi j'embrasse Mamutzu,
j'embrasse Mayotte. Les Mauris sont des
gens absolument adorables, gentils.
Euh les marins pêcheurs sont adorables,
les syndicalistes sur place sont
adorables, les petits épiciers sur place
sont adorables, les infirmières, les
profs, les cantonniers, les loueurs de
voiture, tout le monde. J'ai été là-bas,
les gens ont été absolument l'imam et
adorable. le
j'en garde un souvenir impérissable et
d'une chaleur humaine des des gens en
fait c'est comme des verniers mélangés
avec des cores mélangés c'est c'est
vraiment ça c'est avec la chaleur la
chaleur du coin la tolérance la
l'ouverture d'esprit le
j'embrasse mon imam qui m'a hébergé sur
place et qui sait de quoi je parle et et
voilà et ne garez jamais votre voiture
sous un palmier qui porte
Bah oui, des cocos casser la voiture
ni un manguier. C'est ça par qu'elles
peuvent être très lourdes.
Euh
des spots de plongé magnifiques, des
plongées dérivantes magnifique de la
passantess magnifique
des forêts de Koromou magnifiques.
Vous n'imaginez même pas la la des fonds
marins extraordinaires. J'ai jamais vu
des forêts de Koromou aussi gigantesqu
des des tombants extraordinaire des des
une lumière. Bon, passons
Non, mais je pense que ce que vous dites
en fait, c'est très important parce que
Mayotte, on en parle beaucoup pour les
mauvaises nouvelles et pour ce qui ne va
pas. Et en fait,
notre attachement quand vous dites c'est
un diamant ou une perle,
c'est stratégique mais pour nous c'est
une terre incomparable de beauté. lever
de soleil ou le coucher de soleil à
Mayotte où la lumière est très douce,
très enveloppante. Là, moi je suis
rentrée ce matin mais je
c'est ça c'est ce qui a été le plus dur
avec le cyclone, c'est comme s'il y
avait eu un souffle atomique qui avait
détruit tout toute la nature. L'île
était toute nue.
Alors que Mayotte est un vert émeraude
avec une forêt primaire extrêmement
dense. c'était
et une nature qui est une générosité
folle parce que c'est une terre
volcanique et donc très très dense avec
une végétation et
des animaux totalement endémiques et
c'est une générosité qui se reflète dans
celle des gens. C'est-à-dire que on est
un peu à l'image de notre habitus et
donc
Mayotte
c'est c'est un carrefour et on est nous
heurté dans notre identité parce qu'on
était un peu à l'écart euh des alliats
du monde et on se retrouve aujourd'hui
vraiment complètement
cogné de tous les côtés dans une
identité
un peu enfin insulaire, particulière à
certains égards
pas très progressistes mais en même
temps avec des traditions qui sont très
vivantes, qui sont très belles. Par
exemple à Mayotte, Mayotte est une île
musicale où les gens chantent tous, même
les prières.
C'est une île qui est gourmande. Les
gens adorent manger, adorent cuisiner,
on cuisine de manière communautaire.
Donc on on fait des grands repas, les
familles, les villages,
les communautés se constituent en groupe
de femmes qui vont de circoncision en
mariage, en enterrement pour cuisiner,
pour la communauté. Euh
donc, il y a une gourmandise. On était
une société qui jusqu'à très récemment
ne connaissait pas l'argent. Donc on se
donnait beaucoup à manger, on s'offrait
euh ben les fruits du jardin, du des
champs, de la pêche. Euh
on allait très peu en mer. Moi, j'ai
allais beaucoup parce que notre père
était marin et maman était
métropolitaine et métropolitaine et donc
on avait pas peur de la mer. Mais
culturellement, les les maorés vont très
peu en mer et c'est récent qu'ils
aillent faire des voulés où ils vont
faire des piqueniques sur la mer et
cetera, sur la plage.
Mais c'est un des plus beaux lagons du
monde. Tim Allen, l'ancienne associée de
Steve Jobs, quand il était marin et
quand il était malade sur sa partie
phase terminale est venu avec son yacht
pour plonger à Mayotte et avec son son
sous-marin privé pour voir la beauté du
lagon. tellement c'est un spot qui est
unique au monde qui a été en partie
atteint là avec le cyclone et aussi par
la ninia. Donc on a une phase de
blanchiment des coraux mais moi j'en ai
déjà connu et ils avaient repris vie.
Donc c'est un patrimoine qui est d'une
beauté mais vraiment qui vous saisit.
C'est-à-dire euh Mayotte est tellement
intense que soit pour les étrangers,
c'est un rejet total parce que c'est
trop, soit c'est une passion absolue et
qui disparaît pas. Et moi je dis souvent
qu'il y a des métropolitains qui sont
desmaorés qui sont nés par erreur dans
l'hexagone mais en fait ils sont à la
maison quand ils rentrent, ils
découvrent qu'ils sont chez eux et les
maoré les reconnaissent parce que c'est
des gens qui construisent, qui
s'investissent à Mayotte et qui
s'intègrent complètement.
Et c'est même pas une intégration s'il
rentrent à la maison et ils acceptent
nos traditions, ils y contribuent, il
les renouvelle, on est très curieux, on
est à vie de de de
d'apprendre, de découvrir et donc
Mayotte se transforme très vite.
Pour certains, c'est la peur de perdre
notre identité, mais moi je trouve
qu'elle est tellement riche et profonde
que en fait on a je n'ai pas cette
angoisse. J'ai peur qu'on disparaisse
parce qu'on nous efface mais j'ai pas
peur de qu'on perde notre identité. Mais
pour les plus jeunes, parce que vous
m'aviez posé une question avant de la
concession pour les les jeunes
générations, je rajoute encore un bout
des tortues gigantesques.
Non, les plus grosses elles sont euh
c'est les tortues de terre qui sont à
l'île Maurice. Mais à Mayotte, vous les
voyez dans l'eau.
Dans 1 m dans 1 m de profondeur. J'ai vu
des tortues avec une carapace, je dirais
peut-être 1,50 ou 1,60 de long. Il y a
du requin quand même.
Oui mais non mais non faut pas faut pas
alors
mais du requin à observer.
Voilà. Alors je je on s'explique.
Mayotte est un lagon. Le lagon est
fermé. Donc en fait c'est un espace de
nurserie pour les espèces.
Pour les espèces. Donc les mamans
requins vont dans certaines certains
endroits pour euh élever leur parce que
en gros un lagon la mer est moins
profonde donc les vagues sont moins
fortes. Donc c'est un espace qui permet
de de faire euh qui crée un écosystème
particulier et donc c'est une nurcerie.
Donc il y a très peu de requins dans le
lagon. Les quelques requins que vous
avez pu observer, c'est les dans les
nurseries de requins, c'est les petites
zones où elles vont et les tortues ont
comme caractéristique principale de
toujours revenir pondre au même endroit.
Et donc Mayotte est un lieu de pontte.
Donc on a des lieux où on peut observer
les pou les tortues pondr
et donc il y en a il y en a énormément à
Mayotte. Et ce qui est merveilleux,
c'est que vous les voyez, vous pouvez
observer la la ponte la nuit, il y a des
associations qui le font, mais en fait,
vous pouvez en mer vous retrouver être
en train de nager et voir une tortue. Et
en fait, c'est non seulement extrêmement
gracieux, mais c'est très rapide. Une
tortue va très vite en mer, en fait et
donc il y a rien de plus contradictoire
par rapport au dicton et la version
qu'on peut la vision qu'on en a dans
l'hexagone.
Tortue dasche pas, une tortue vole. Elle
volle, c'est vrai. Et la troisième
chose, c'est qu'il y a des baleines
aussi à Mayotte qu'on observe et qui
sont très belles parce qu'elles viennent
aussi pour euh leur pour apprendre avec
leur balineau à nager euh dans le lagon.
Donc c'est vraiment c'est un écosystème
qui est qui est exceptionnel. Moi je le
l'attachement à notre terre est
charnelle. C'est une terre rouge parce
qu'elle est volcanique.
Euh le sable des plages est noir, il est
très rarement blanc
et c'est une eau qui est qui est
sublime. Et pour nos jeunes, enfin pour
moi ce qui est important c'est que on
dépasse culturellement notre peur de
l'eau pour aller nager, pour aller dans
l'eau et pour découvrir parce qu'en fait
on connaît notre trésor terrestre mais
très peu notre trésor sous-marin.
Et en fait pour pouvoir mieux le
protéger, il faut y aller. Et en fait
Mayotte c'est un aquarium. Vous n'avez
pas besoin d'avoir des des
des bouteilles. En fait, vous plongez
juste comme ça et vous mettez la tête
dans un m de flotte.
Voilà. Et vous êtes dans un aquarium.
Mais c'est un éblouissement parce que
quand vous le faites avec des gens qui
l'ont jamais fait, qui viennent et qui
voient, c'est vraiment c'est saisissant
parce que c'est tout un monde. Moi, pour
moi, c'est aller en mer, c'est mon grand
bonheur. C'est vraiment mon grand
bonheur. C'est le lieu où je suis le
plus heureuse sur terre. un un poisson
ne vote pas, pose pas de questions, il
est juste beau et j'adore aller en
merde. J'ai pas pu depuis quasiment un
an depuis en fait. J'ai pas du tout eu
le temps de puis la flotte a aussi été
détruite.
Un autre un autre conseil pour les
jeunes générations.
Alors pour les jeunes générations, je
sais pas si je suis je suis très
pertinente, moi je pense
ne vous laissez pas contaminer par les
angoisses des anciens. Nos échecs ne
sont pas les vôtres. Ne préjugent pas de
votre avenir. Vous avez tout à
construire, tout à faire.
C'est pas euh
c'est c'est c'est aussi plein
d'opportunités. Je trouve que le
discours sur les jeunes est très
anxiogène, que c'est pas facile pour eux
et je voudrais leur dire de qu'en fait
on va laisser peut-être un énorme
merdier derrière nous, mais en fait ça
veut dire aussi qu'ils auront plein de
choses à faire et à inventer et que
toutes les révolutions qui sont en train
de se dérouler leur offrent aussi
énormément de possibilités. On va pas
laisser un héritage incroyable à
certains égards, mais on va laisser
aussi de très beaux outils. Et c'est des
outils, c'est ce qu'on décide d'en faire
qui qui importe. Et pour eux, il y aura
quand même, je pense, beaucoup de choses
à faire. Pour les anciennes générations,
c'est très euh on on projette sur nos
propres angoisses et nos propres
interrogations, mais je trouve qu'on
leur interdit euh
la possibilité de rêver, d'imaginer. Et
en fait euh mais il faut il faut y
aller, faut taper dedans. C'est le
bordel, allez-y. C'est c'est au
contraire euh sentez-vous libre comme il
y a plus de règles. Let's go.
Estelle Youssoufa, merci.
Merci à vous.